tolles Programm und wie sie das gewohnt
sind können Sie das ganze hier bei
Phoenix live verfolgen es geht natürlich
um Energie um Gas etc es geht um den
Ukraine Krieg aber gleich zu Beginn
beschäftigen sich die Abgeordneten hier
mit einem sehr wichtigen Thema nämlich
mit der digitalstrategie der
Bundesregierung die deutsche Wirtschaft
leidet nicht nur unter den hohen
Energiepreisen sondern auch unter der
fehlenden Digitalisierung in der größten
Volkswirtschaft in Europa so haben nur
6,3 Prozent der deutschen Haushalte
einen Glasfaseranschluss im
internationalen Vergleich ist das nur
Platz 78 vorne liegen die Arabischen
Emirate mit fast 97% gefolgt von
Singapur 95,8 und China
94,9 Prozent der europäische Index für
digitale Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft da
rangiert Deutschland nur auf Platz 13
und bei der Durchdringung der
Wirtschaftsunternehmen mit digital da
liegt Deutschland nur auf Platz 16 da
muss also einiges passieren und der
zuständige digitalminister und
Verkehrsminister Volker Wissing hat die
digitalstrategie in Meseberg bei der
Klausur vorgestellt und heute beraten
also die Abgeordneten und das wollen
will ich auch tun mit meinen beiden
Gästen ich begrüße ganz herzlich Carina
Konrad stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der FDP und Nadine
schön in der gleichen Funktion für die
cdu/csu
Frau Konrad guten Morgen bevor wir über
die Inhalte quasi reden zunächst mal zur
Struktur also ich war schon ein bisschen
überrascht als die Ampel sich gebildet
hat das ist kein eigenes
digitalministerium vielleicht mit
Bildung gibt das war gerade von vielen
fdp-politikern immer gefordert worden
selbst aus der Union gab es diese
Stimmen und die Union hat heute einen
eigenen Antrag vorgelegt der fordert sie
das auch das Problem ist ja dass eben in
den vergangenen Legislaturperioden
dieses Thema immer so ein bisschen
aufgesplittet war keiner wusste wer
dafür zuständig ist jetzt hat also der
Verkehrsminister nach wie vor den Hut
auf das war in der vergangenen Regierung
auch so und hat wieder viele Dinge weg
delegiert das ist doch wieder eine
Zersplitterung
der digitalminister hat jetzt den Hut
auf das haben Sie richtig gesagt und der
große Erfolg der ja auch sich hinter
dieser digitalstrategie verbirgt ist das
jetzt alle Ressorts auch Zulieferern und
sich verbindliche Ziele geben und
darüber tatsächlich dann auch als oder
man kann es auch sagen darunter als
Fundament das gebaut wird was notwendig
ist in Deutschland um tatsächlich
Digitalisierung wirklich voranzubringen
und sich nicht immer nur um klein zu
verlieren und den Stillstand zu
verwalten wie das in der Vergangenheit
war ist dass man mit drei hebelprojekten
wirklich auch die Grundlage dafür setzt
das jetzt Digitalisierung auch in der
Fläche ausgerollt wird und auch so dass
die Menschen das merken und spürbare
Verbesserung merken und das vor allen
Dingen auch sie haben es gerade erwähnt
die Unternehmen eine spürbare
Verbesserung merken wir haben diese
Krise und gerade weil wir im Moment die
Krisen haben ist es umso wichtiger
tatsächlich jetzt auch Deutschland zu
modernisieren um dann auch mit Schwung
noch mal nach vorne schauen zu können
noch mal ganz kurz zurückgeschaut mit
Ihnen Frau schön denn schließlich hat
die cdu/csu 16 Jahre die Bundeskanzlerin
gestellt es wurde Überflug Taxi
spekuliert etc und am Schluss kam
reichlich wenig raus ich habe ja die
bitteren eben vorgelesen was ist da
schief gelaufen war es nur die
Organisation oder ist das so ein
orchideen-thema dass man einfach dann
gerne auch mal links liegen lässt es
wurden nicht nur über flugtaxis
spekuliert es gibt jetzt flugtaxen also
ich wunder mich auch dass der
Verkehrsminister sich so lustig macht
die ganze Zeit über das Thema aber um
auf Ihre Frage zu antworten wir haben in
der Vergangenheit gesehen dass es mehr
Koordinierung braucht bei der
digitalpolitik wir hatten das in der
letzten Legislaturperiode aus dem
Kanzleramt heraus gemacht eine Steuerung
über alle Ressorts hinweg und die
Erkenntnis war dass wir das noch mit
mehr unterfüttern müssen dass es ein
eigenes digitalministerium braucht was
eine Steuerungsfunktion hat was
Mitarbeiter hat die diese Koordinierung
machen können und das war auch immer der
Wunsch der FDP was haben sie jetzt
gemacht sie haben das noch mal
zurückgegliedert in die ressourstruktur
haben nur den Namen getauscht beim
Verkehrsminister der heißt jetzt
Minister für digitales und Verkehr und
der hat aber nicht mehr Kompetenzen als
früher Semester und er sagt auch selbst
also die digitalstrategie liegt jetzt da
ab sofort ist jedes Haus dafür
verantwortlich dass die Projekte
umgesetzt werden wir finden in dieser
Strategie keine messbaren Ziele ganz
wenige wir finden keine klare Steuerung
kein Monitoring und es wird mehr oder
weniger den Zufall überlassen wie sich
das in den nächsten Jahren
weiterentwickelt da muss ich sagen da
ist aus den der Vergangenheit nicht
gelernt worden im Gegenteil es ein
Rückschritt
Minister hat Ziele definiert bis 2025
und dann die Endziele quasi bis zum
Jahre 20 30 er hat 18 Leuchtturm
Projekte benannt zum Beispiel die
Glasfaserverkabelung 50% bis zum Jahr
2025 da sagen viele das ist wenig
ambitioniert allerdings bevor wir ins
kleinere gehen gucken wir mal aufs große
eine der Hauptkritikpunkte ist ja es
steht überhaupt nichts über Geld da drin
das ist natürlich hochsensibel in der
Zeit jetzt wo wir sehen dass es an allen
Ecken und Enden fehlt muss man doch
Sorge tragen dass diese Projekte niemals
mit Leben erfüllt werden können
also erstmal will ich schon bin ich froh
dass es klargestellt natürlich sind klar
definierte Ziele drin wenn man sich
selbst Jahreszahlen gibt als
Bundesregierung finde ich das als
Abgeordneter schon mal in ziemlich guten
Richtwert dafür dass wir nachher auch
genau schauen können wie schnell jetzt
die Ressorts umsetzen und natürlich
hängt auch alles mit Geld zusammen und
in den Ressorts gibt es ja jeweils auch
digital Budgets für die einzelnen
Maßnahmen aber was wichtig ist und das
will ich auch noch mal betonen an der
Stelle ist tatsächlich dass man sie
Grundlage jetzt endlich mal schafft man
kann viel über klein klein reden und das
wurde auch in der Vergangenheit viel
getan aber wenn man wirklich einen
Nutzen für die Unternehmen für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in diesem Land
haben will dann muss man auch das
Fundament bauen dafür dass
Digitalisierung überhaupt in der Fläche
notwendig ist wir haben bis heute keine
digitalen IDs wir haben bis heute zu
wenig Glasfaser in der Flasche wir haben
zu wenig 5g-anschlüsse und Ausbau und
der Fläche und auch ist immer
Vereinheitlichung Standards bei Daten
damit auch ein weltweiter in Europa
weiter Austausch stattfinden kann ist
ganz zentral dafür dass auch wirklich
ein messbarer Mehrwert nachher da ist
und das sind Dinge die jetzt auch
angegangen werden und ehrlicherweise die
auch lange schon hätten erledigt sein
können wir haben ja gar kein Lizenz
deshalb wundert mich das auch dass dann
einfach immer nur gemeckert wird was
könnte noch besser noch mehr noch
schneller sein das ist auch die Aufgabe
der Opposition ganz eindeutig aber wir
müssen tatsächlich auch an einem Strang
ziehen erkennen dass das hier jetzt
wirklich ein zentrales Projekt ist um
Deutschland auch nur zu modernisieren
und diesen Stillstand zu beenden da hat
man es einfach in der Opposition Kritik
ist da ja quasi eingepreist Frau schön
Peter Altmaier hat sehr häufig gesagt
ich traue mich überhaupt nicht und ich
mache das auch nicht mehr aus Autos oder
Zügen meine Ministerkollegen in Europa
oder woanders anzurufen das ist ja
peinlich weil wir nach wie vor natürlich
in Deutschland wirklich eine also gerade
im Telefonbereich eine ein System haben
was wirklich weit hinten liegt sage ich
mal vorsichtig auch da hat ja die
Zustände haben die zuständigen Minister
der Union ja nicht absichtlich versagt
sondern das liegt natürlich auch an
einem Punkt der klar diskutiert werden
muss den hat er bisschen ja auch benannt
da geht es nämlich um die
Kompetenzstreitigkeiten zwischen
Kommunen Ländern und Bund also mal eben
da überall solche Telefonmasten
hochzuziehen 5g mal eben an der Seite
von Bahnstrecken zu installieren hört
sich gut an funktioniert aber deswegen
nicht haben sie eine Lösung wie man das
ändern kann
ja in der gigabit-strategie sind ja
Lösungen drin und die setzen auch auf
dem auf was wir vorbereitet haben wir
haben in der letzten Legislaturperiode
einen Telekommunikationsgesetz neu
geschaffen was es zum Beispiel
ermöglicht in den Häusern die inhouse
Verkabelung also wirklich das Glasfaser
bis ins Haus zu erleichtern da müsstet
die Regierung jetzt ansetzen und
weitermachen wir haben bei
mobilfunkausbau bei der letzten Auktion
als Parlament darauf gedrängt dass die
versorgungsauflagen stärker werden das
erwarte ich jetzt natürlich auch bei der
nächsten Auktion und vor allem dürfen
wir nicht nur Auflagen machen sondern
die Bundesnetzagentur muss das auch noch
strenger Monitoren strenger kontrolliert
und selbst Messungen machen denn dass
die gefühlte der gefühlte Ausbau ist
nicht der gleiche wie die
Mobilfunkunternehmen sagen was er
ausgebaut haben auch in den Rankings wir
sind gut vorangekommen aber die Bedarfe
werden eben auch größer wir brauchen
heute viel mehr Datenmengen als wir es
noch vor wenigen Jahren gebraucht werden
und deshalb muss auch da Wachstum
genauso mitgehen da sind wir auf einem
guten Weg in der Anhörung wurde auch
gesagt im Prinzip ist sind die Ziele die
da jetzt drin stehen ist das was alles
schon vorbereitet war also wenn da jetzt
wirklich eine Schippe draufgelegt werden
soll dann braucht es eben auch konkrete
Maßnahmen da hat der Minister auch zwei
drei vorgeschlagen leider hat das sie
teilweise wieder einkassiert wie zum
Beispiel den Fonds von dem wir gar nicht
wissen ob er kommt oder ob er nicht
kommt Glasfaserkabel ist das Stichwort
8,1 Millionen Haushalte da liegt das
Glasfaserkabel an aber nur 3 muss ich
selber mal gucken 3,8 Millionen
Haushalte haben bisher ein Vertrag
abgeschlossen 12 Millionen Leitungen
liegen in der Nähe und der Recht ist
Schweigen wir haben über 40 Millionen
Haushalte man hat ausgerechnet wenn man
das Glasfaserkabel so verlegt wie es
vorgesehen ist nämlich mit 60 cm tiefer
tiefbauweise dann wird das ewig dauern
in Deutschland Glasfaserkabel komplett
hat deswegen gibt es ja jetzt diese
ritzmethode dass man den Asphalt nur
anritzt da sagen jetzt aber die Kommunen
schon das ist gefährlich da gibt es
Schäden und jetzt wird schon als erstes
wieder über einen Fonds berichtet den
der Minister plant das kostet alles
wahnsinniges Geld und wie geht's
schneller ja sie haben gerade so ein
bisschen richtig schön auch die die
Problematik die Widersprüche aufgezählt
auf der einen Seite sagt natürlich jeder
er will das haben aber wenn dann die
Baumaßnahme vor der eigenen Haustür
stattfindet in der eigenen Kommune gab
es ja oft immer Widerstände ich glaube
schon dass ich dieser Geist geändert hat
vor allen Dingen weil sich dieser Geist
auch mittlerweile in der Politik
insgesamt geändert hat wir haben in der
letzten Legislaturperiode noch vernommen
dass man 5g eben nicht an jeder
Milchkanne bräuchte ich glaube
mittlerweile gibt es doch Einigkeit
darüber dass man das braucht und dass
wir um Deutschland zu modernisieren auf
voran kommen muss und das hängt auch
ganz viel damit zusammen wie schnell
solche Dinge gehen und welche Verfahren
angewendet werden wie Ausschreibungen
designt werden da gab es in der
Vergangenheit glaube ich auch
Erkenntnisse die in der Zukunft zu
Verbesserungen führen können wenn man
gerade darüber redet welche Methoden
werden angewendet aber auch wie designt
man den Ausschreibungen überhaupt damit
man auch schneller vorkommt weil am Ende
muss das Kabel gelegt werden dafür
braucht es auch Menschen die das machen
dafür braucht es aber auch die
Bereitschaft von Kommunen das mit
umsetzen zu wollen und wenn ich bei mir
so ein Wahlkreis unterwegs bin sehe ich
überall Schilder wo tatsächlich im
Moment auch dafür geworben wird und
angekündigt wird das Glasfaser jetzt
auch in die in die Fläche kommt und dass
wir da jetzt noch schneller werden und
auch im ausschreibungsdesign auch im
förderdesign so vorgehen dass die
unterversorgten Flächen dann auch
versorgt werden das ist ein großer
Gewinn und das haben wir halt auch jetzt
fest vor Frau schön was kann Berlin von
Schleswig-Holstein lernen
Schleswig-Holstein hat 61%
Glasfaserkabel Anliegen Berlin nur 10
und Berlin hat auch den traurigen
letzten Platz in der 5g-technik was
läuft da falsch na es kommt sehr darauf
an wie das vor Ort umgesetzt wird im
Saarland haben wir für das ganze Land
eine zentrale Ausschreibung gemacht und
da läuft der Ausbau der
Glasfaseranbindung in jedes Haus
flächendeckend weil die Landesregierung
sich zentral dem Thema angenommen hat
das ist ein anderen Länder leider nicht
so da können wir als Bund auch nur
bedingt was machen aber was wir eben
machen können sind die Rahmenbedingungen
machen und Frau Konrad hat jetzt eben
auf Ihre Frage nicht geantwortet was
nämlich zum Beispiel mit diesem Fond ist
der dazu dienen soll wenn man diese
Alternativen verlege-methoden macht also
nur das trenching-verfahren im Bordstein
und es passiert was es gibt ja
die Straße geht kaputt dann hat der
Minister angekündigt einen vorzuschaffen
um diese Schäden dann aus diesem vor
heraus zu bezahlen mittlerweile ist in
der Strategie nur noch ein Prüfauftrag
und es gibt auch Streit darüber wer
diesen Form bezahlen soll es gibt noch
kein Konzept ich weiß nicht ob er kommt
deswegen teile ich ja alle Ziele und
sehe auch die Bedarfe aber ich sehe noch
nicht dass das was in der
gigabit-strategie drinsteht die jetzt
ein halbes Jahr alt ist dass die Themen
auch progressiv angegangen werden und
warum ist das alles so wichtig also die
deutschen Industrieunternehmen nur zu
auf Platz 16 in Europa was die
Verkabelung zum Beispiel an
der Minister gesagt wir müssen
mindestens zu Platz 10 kommen und jeder
Bürger merkt es ja täglich also wenn man
Personalausweis braucht dann
Führerschein das dauert alles ewig
selbst die Ukrainer die zu uns kommen
Lächeln darüber bei denen lief es viel
besser also gerade auch in dem Bereich
der Verwaltung warum schafft es
Deutschland nicht den E-Perso
naheausweis endlich einzuführen und in
ein Handy zu integrieren ja das ist eine
Frage die habe ich mir auch gestellt als
als wir in dieser Legislaturperiode
zusammengekommen sind dann auch
Koalitionsverhandlungen geführt haben
und die haben wir uns ehrlicherweise
alle zusammengestellt als Ampelkoalition
und deshalb wird es da jetzt auch so
kommen dass wir diese digitale
Identitäten schaffen die die
Voraussetzungen sind dafür dass all das
man den Führerschein digitalisiert hat
dass man seinen Pass digitalisiert dass
man auch sein kurbelt Zertifikat
beispielsweise digitalisiert hat und
vieles vieles mehr dass sie
Voraussetzung dafür dass wir auch in der
Digitalisierung der Verwaltung
Vorankommen weil Digitalisierung das ist
mehr als als ein Blatt Papier zu einer
PDF einzuscannen und und irgendwo
abzulegen digital sondern ist es
tatsächlich auch das Bürgerinnen und
Bürger in ihrem Alter Erfahrungen haben
und das ist auch spürbar ist für
Unternehmen gerade bei
gewerbesteueranmeldungen bei vielen
Dingen die Unternehmen heute wahnsinnig
belasten bürokratisch in ihrem Alltag
das ist da auch zu spürbaren
Vereinfachungen kommt damit unser
Unternehmensstandort auch nachhaltig und
wettbewerbsfähig ist klingt immer gut
wenn es dann in die reale Umsetzung geht
dann dauert das ewig ich höre die
Klingel sie müssen rein aber eins kann
ich Ihnen noch mitteilen sie müssen
heute sehr lange da bleiben denn kurz
vor Mitternacht berät der Bundestag ein
Gesetz was er selber gut beschließen
kann meine Damen und Herren da geht es
nämlich darum dass die Gesetze in
Deutschland demnächste digital
veröffentlicht werden und nicht mehr im
Bundesgesetzblatt dafür braucht man
allerdings eine Grundgesetzänderung aber
ich denke dieses Gesetz lässt sich
durchsetzen und wird sicherlich
eingesetzt sein was in dieser
Legislaturperiode verabschiedet wird wir
wollen alle hoffen dass die
digitalstrategie diesmal in den nächsten
vier Jahren so umgesetzt wird dass
sowohl die Industrie als auch die
Privatpersonen in Deutschland endlich
auf einem normalen Level leben können
und ich gebe jetzt rein in den Bundestag
[Musik]
meine Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ich wünsche einen schönen
guten Morgen die Sitzung ist eröffnet
zunächst
schönen guten Morgen zunächst gratuliere
ich dem Kollegen Dietrich monstadt
nachträglich zu seinem 65 geburtstag im
Namen des ganzen Hauses alles Gute fürs
neue Lebensjahr
[Applaus]
dann gestatten Sie mir bitte ein ganz
besonderen Glückwunsch heute morgen
auszusprechen
am vergangenen Sonntag hat Wolfgang
Schäuble sein 80 Geburtstag begangen
sehr geehrter Herr Dr Schäuble 50 Jahre
im Deutschen Bundestag 14 mal direkt
gewählt eine Bilanz die in diesem Hause
denke ich einmalig ist
deshalb werden wir auch im Dezember die
Zeit uns die Zeit nehmen
ihr 50 Jubiläum als
Bundestagsabgeordneter angemessen zu
würdigen ihr 80 Geburtstag ist
selbstverständlich auch grund genug
schon heute an ihre Verdienste kurz zu
erinnern die wichtigste ist zweifellos
die deutsche Einheit wenig später haben
sie auch hier ihre vielleicht sogar
berühmteste Rede gehalten auch dank
ihres Plädoyers für den Umzug nach
Berlin Tagen wir nämlich heute hier in
diesem historischen Reichstagsgebäude
sie waren darüber hinaus stets ein
überzeugter Europäer und haben die
heutige Europäische Union mitgebaut vor
allem unsere Beziehung zu Frankreich
liegen ihnen ganz besonders am Herzen
das beste Beispiel dafür ist sicherlich
die deutsch-französische
Parlamentarierversammlung und über
Jahrzehnte haben sie politische
Verantwortung getragen dieses Parlament
haben sie nahezu von allen Perspektiven
aus betrachten können als Abgeordneter
als Fraktionsvorsitzender auch von der
Regierungsbank aus und nicht zuletzt
auch hier oben als Präsident dieses
Hauses
sie streiten mit Leidenschaft für die
parlamentarische Demokratie und sie
mahnen uns immer wieder dass die
Demokratie keine Selbstverständlichkeit
ist und Sie haben für Deutschland und
für dieses Parlament insgesamt viel
geleistet dafür danke ich Ihnen im Namen
des ganzen Hauses und auch ganz
persönlich und herzlichen Glückwunsch
dazu
[Applaus]
Applaus des ganzen Hauses Standing
Ovations für Wolfgang Schäuble und das
auch mit Recht wenn man es aus Sicht
eines Parlamentariers auch eines
Parlamentariers der nicht in der CDU ist
sieht seit 50 Jahren
sitzt Wolfgang Schäuble als Abgeordneter
im deutschen Parlament er war ja auch
der Vorgänger von Bärbel Bars als
zweiter Mann im Staat
Bundestagsvizepräsident und hatte
verschiedene Ministerposten
Kanzleramtsminister Innenminister war er
und wie gesagt also die Krönung dann
Bundestags Präsident
nun fahren wir fort vor mit der Tag oder
vor der Tagesordnung müssen wir noch
natürlich war Finanzminister das lange
Jahre und auch sehr reibungsvoll wenn
Sie sich an die Zeit der Griechenland
helfen erinnern jetzt geht es also hier
in der Tagesordnung los mit der
digitalstrategie der Bundesregierung
aber erst wird hier noch
als Mitglied gewählt werden sind Sie
damit einverstanden das sieht so aus so
jetzt gibt es noch schöne Wahl eines
nachrückers glaube ich in das Kuratorium
Wissenschaftszentrum Berlin für
Sozialforschung sollen auf Vorschlag der
Fraktion der SPD der Abgeordnete Rupert
Stüwe und auch Vorschlag der Fraktion
der cdu/csu der Abgeordnete Klaus-peter
Wilsch als Mitglieder gewählt werden
ich sehe auch damit sind Sie
einverstanden dann sind die beiden
Kollegen als Mitglieder gewählt auf
Vorschlag der CDU-Fraktion
der cdu/csu-fraktion soll weiter der
Abgeordnete Michael dont in den Beirat
der Schlichtungsstelle für den
öffentlichen Personennahverkehr
als Nachfolger für den ausgeschiedenen
Abgeordneten Sebastian Steinecke für die
restliche Amtszeit gewählt werden
stimmen Sie dem auch zu
das sieht offensichtlich der Fall damit
ist der Kollege dont in den Beirat
gewählt
[Applaus]
abschließend soll in den Verwaltungsrat
der
filmförderungsanstalt auf Vorschlag der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen der
Abgeordnete Michael Sacher als
Nachfolger für die Abgeordnete Luise
Amtsberg als ordentliches Mitglied für
die restliche Amtszeit gewählt werden
ich sehe damit sind sie auch
einverstanden dann ist der Kollege
Sacher auch gewählt ich komme
schließlich zur Tagesordnung
Tagesordnungspunkt 8 wird abgesetzt an
diese Stelle tritt Taten und
Tagesordnungspunkt 23 mit einer Dauer
von 26 Minuten Beratungszeit auch damit
sind Sie einverstanden ich sehe kein
Widerspruch dann ist das so beschlossen
ich rufe auf die Tagesordnungspunkte 7a
bis 7c Beratung der Unterrichtung durch
die Bundesregierung über ihre digital
und ihre
[ __ ] Strategie sowie Beratung des
Antrags der Fraktion der cdu/csu mit dem
Titel Stillstand und unklare
Zuständigkeiten in der digitalpolitik
beenden für eine ambitionierte und
koordinierte digitalstrategie für die
Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von 68
Minuten beschlossen ich eröffne die
Aussprache und das Wort hat für die
Bundesregierung der Bundesminister für
digitales und Verkehr dr Volker Wissing
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wer ins Ausland reist macht
häufig eine sehr ernüchternde Erfahrung
nämlich das andere beim Thema
Digitalisierung weiter sind als wir
beim Vergleich der 27 EU-Mitgliedstaaten
belegt die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
gerade mal Platz 13
das ist eine Bilanz die so nicht bleiben
kann das was wir übernommen haben von
der Vorgängerregierung über Bereich der
Digitalisierung kann sich nicht sehen
lassen Deutschland muss in der Top-Liga
spielen wir können uns Platz 13 nicht
leisten deshalb ist klar deutschland
braucht ein umfassenden digitalen
Aufbruch
das Kursbuch dafür ist die
digitalstrategie der Bundesregierung sie
führt erstmals die digitalpolitischen
Schwerpunkte aller Ministerien zusammen
und zeigt sehr konkret wie der Staat das
Leben der Bürgerinnen und Bürger mit
Hilfe der Digitalisierung verbessern
will und auch verbessern wird dabei
haben wir drei hebelprojekte definiert
die Grundlage für viele digitale
Anwendungen sind zum einen wäre das die
digitalen Identitäten denn um
datenbasierte Leistungen und Dienste im
Netz sicher nutzen zu können brauchen
wir sichere digitale Identitäten also
etwa bei onlinebehördengängen bei
Gesundheitsdienstleistungen beim
Beantragen des Personalausweises oder
auch im privatschaft wirtschaftlichen
Bereich etwa beim Online-Shopping beim
zweiten hebelprojekt geht es um
internationale Standards einheitliche
technische Standards ermöglichen
Interoperabilität das heißt sie sorgen
dafür dass alles zusammenpasst
wichtig ist daher dass wir die in
unserer Strategie beschriebenen Projekte
technisch offen und rechtlich sicher
gestalten das ist entscheidend für alle
digitalpolitischen Vorhaben die jedes
Ressort in eigener Verantwortung
umsetzen muss das dritte hebelprojekt
schließlich ist der gigabit-ausbau und
einer deutlichen höhere Verfügbarkeit
von Daten
denn Daten sind der Schlüssel für
digitale Innovationen wenn man sie
analysiert aufbereitet verknüpft können
daraus ganz neue Geschäftsmodelle
entstehen neue Produktionsmöglichkeiten
und natürlich optimierte Abläufe darin
liegen Herausforderungen und Chance
gleichermaßen für den Standort
Deutschland deshalb setzen wir auf Open
Data also den grundsatzdaten öffentlich
für jedermann frei verfügbar und nutzbar
zu machen und wir setzen auf Datenräume
die in rechtssicheren Austausch von
Daten ermöglichen außerdem enthält
unsere digitalstrategie 18
Leuchtturmprojekte der einzelnen
Ressorts sie betreffen die
unterschiedlichsten Lebensbereiche und
tragen allesamt dazu bei dass die Dinge
bei uns künftig einfacher und
effizienter ablaufen dabei haben wir
konkrete Ziele definiert an denen wir
uns am Ende dieser Legislaturperiode im
Jahr 2025 messen lassen wollen
den Personalausweis beantragen einen
neuen Wohnort mitteilen oder ein neues
Unternehmen anmelden dass alles muss
künftig in wenigen Minuten vom Sofa aus
quasi von zu Hause aus erledigt werden
können daher sollen bis 2025
Personalausweis und Führerschein digital
auch auf dem Smartphone sein
im Gesundheitsbereich etwa wollen wir
erreichen dass mindestens 80 Prozent der
gesetzlich Versicherten die
elektronische Patientenakte nutzen und
bis fangen 2025 soll mindestens die
Hälfte aller Anschlüsse mit Glasfaser
versorgt sein und außerdem sollen alle
im Mobilfunk bis 2026 drahtlose Sprach-
und Datendienste verlässlich
flächendeckend nutzen können denn klar
ist Homeoffice Streaming im ICE und
empfangen auf der Berghütte müssen
endlich auch in Deutschland problemlos
möglich sein
dafür meine Damen und Herren haben wir
eine gigabit-strategie beschlossen mit
den darin enthaltenen Maßnahmen schaffen
wir die Bedingungen und die digitalen
Netze jetzt schneller und effizienter
auszubauen und wenn ich mir anschaue wie
das in den letzten Monaten vorangegangen
ist dann haben wir unsere Ziele schon
überfällt das läuft richtig gut und vor
allem müssen wir auch
Genehmigungsverfahren gemeinsam mit den
Ländern weiter vereinfachen und
beschleunigen beim Glasfaserausbau zum
Beispiel soll ein digitaler Antrag
ermöglicht werden zudem stärken wir
alternative Verlegetechniken mit denen
ein schneller Ausbau möglich ist unter
der Erde aber auch oberirdisch und gute
Nachrichten kommen in dem Zusammenhang
aus der Telekommunikationsbranche selbst
für die kommenden Jahre hat sie
Investitionen von 50 Milliarden Euro
angekündigt allein in den
Glasfaserausbau es ist unsere Aufgabe
dafür zu sorgen dass sie diese Mittel
schnell und zielführend investieren kann
denn der eigenwirtschaftliche Ausbau hat
für uns natürlich Vorrang vor
staatlicher Förderung
und meine Damen und Herren damit das
alles erfolgreich gelingt steuern und
begleiten wir die Umsetzung unserer
digitalstrategie mit einem Monitoring so
können wir beobachten und bewerten wie
wir mit der Umsetzung vorankommen und
wenn es hakt können wir rechtzeitig
nachsteuern wir wollen aber auch gerade
bei Maßnahmen mit großer Hebelwirkung
überprüfen ob sie effizient sind ob sie
tatsächlich effizient wirken das ist ein
wichtiger Schritt hin zu einem Lernenden
digitalen Staat einem Staat der
vorausschauend für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger arbeitet ich bin überzeugt dass
die
gigabit-strategie und die
digitalstrategie zusammen den digitalen
Aufbruch in Deutschland ermöglichen den
Aufbruch den unser Land dringend
benötigt damit schaffen wir
damit
schaffen wir mehr Teilhabe mehr Chancen
und mehr Fortschritt für alle und lassen
sie mich zum Schluss sagen weil ich
wahrscheinlich jetzt gleich von der
Opposition erfahren werde dass das alles
viel zu langsam gegangen ist in den
letzten 12 Monaten wir haben einen
Aufholbedarf weil sie uns die
Deutschland in einem Zustand
hinterlassen haben indem man feststellen
muss indem man feststellen muss dass wir
im digitalen in vielen Punkten erst am
Anfang stehen vielen Dank
der digitalminister Volker Wissing
stellt hier die digitalstrategie der
Bundesregierung vor auf 52 Seiten
zusammengetragen 18 Leuchtturmprojekte
und solche Selbstverständlichkeiten wie
glasfaserkable digitale
Verwaltungsleistung die in anderen
Ländern selbstverständlich sind die muss
der Minister jetzt
herbeischaffen bis 2025 will er 50%
Glasfaserkabel Nadine schön jetzt für
die Union Minister wissen sie lassen
sich in den letzten
Tieren dass sie sich nicht in
Zukunftsvisionen wie flugtaxis verlieren
wollen sondern ganz konkret den
Glasfaserausbau
ich finde das bemerkenswert denn ganz
ehrlich sie legen eine Strategie vor
sagen aber Visionen lehnen sie ab und da
frage ich mich wurde auf arbeiten sie
denn hin wie kann man denn eine
Strategie vorlegen wenn man das Ziel wo
man hin will gar nicht definiert
digitalpolitik ist weit mehr als
gigabit-ausbau digitalpolitik muss ich
einbetten in eine wirtschaftspolitische
Dimension in eine
gesellschaftspolitische Dimension eine
sicherheitspolitische und auch und das
merken wir doch in den letzten Monaten
massiv in eine geostrategische Position
und in dieser Situation zu sagen dass
interessiert mich gar nicht Visionen
damit habe ich nichts zu tun ich
definiere gar kein Ziel wo ich hin will
das finde ich schon sehr bemerkenswert
und das zweite Problem ist die Strategie
ist keine wirkliche Strategie weil jeder
Unternehmensstrategie finden Sie
Meilensteine Etappenzielen und
Kennzahlen und können danach auch
steuern wir haben zwar eben gehört dass
wir Ziele definiert haben aber entweder
sind diese Ziele so ambitionslos dass
Sie davon sieht dass man die sofort
erfüllen kann Stichwort Gigabit bis 25
in 50 Prozent der Haushalte am Montag
hatten wir Anhörung alle haben gesagt
naja das schafft er ja locker das ist ja
schon auf dem Weg das ist überhaupt
nicht ambitioniert oder auch im in
diesem desin-ranking der Europäischen
Kommission wo der Minister eben
kritisiert hat dass wir nur auf Platz 13
sind sein Ziel Platz 10 Frau schön
gestatten sie eine Zwischenfrage aus der
FDP-Fraktion
ja vielen Dank liebe Kolleginnen das
sind die Zwischenfrage zulassen sie
haben gerade kritisiert diese Strategie
sei zu ambitionslos und die Ziele die
darin definiert sein seien so gering
dass man sie ja locker erreichen können
und deshalb frage ich mich jetzt an der
Stelle einfach mal warum sind diese
Ziele denn nicht lange erreicht wenn die
so einfach zu erreichen gewesen wären
denn immerhin war es ja auch ihre
Fraktion die in den letzten Jahren die
Regierung unterstützt hat dabei
Digitalisierung nur zu verwalten statt
zu gestalten und da frage ich mich jetzt
wirklich wo liegt jetzt eigentlich der
Kern ihrer Kritik ist es nur dass sie
nicht selbst daran beteiligt waren diese
digitalstrategie jetzt vorzulegen oder
ist es tatsächlich fundiert dass ihnen
wirklich Visionen fehlen obwohl wir die
Grundlagen dafür noch nicht mal
geschaffen haben
liebe Frau Kollegin Conrad sie finden in
dieser Strategie quer durch alle Seiten
Ziele die die aus also Maßnahmen wo die
Ausgangslage genannt wird und dann steht
darin da wollen wir uns verbessern ohne
ein Ziel dazu zu nennen wo sie denn
dahin kommen wollen sie haben bei der
Landwirtschaft wollen sie sich daran
messen lassen dass die Anwendung
digitaler Technologien in der
Landwirtschaft zugenommen hat ja um wie
viel denn sie sagen nicht wie viel
Fachkräfte wir mehr wollen sie sagen
nicht wie viel mehr Frauen wir in den
digitalberufen haben wollen sie sagen
nicht wie viel Unicorns werden unserem
Land brauchen damit sie das als Erfolg
deklarieren Sie sagen wir wollen von
allem mehr und das ist für sie dann ein
ambitioniertes Ziel ist es nicht die FDP
hat immer gesagt wir wollen greifbare
Ziele und wir wollen ein Monitoring und
davon ist ja kaum etwas zu finden
und liebe Kollegen Kollegen bei den
wirklichen Schlüsselthemen haben sie
jetzt schon nach einem Jahr einen
wahnsinnigen
Abkehr von dem was sie im
Koalitionsvertrag noch versprochen
hatten im Koalitionsvertrag und den
sondierungspapieren haben sie gesagt der
Schlüssel damit wir leistungsfähiger
sind in Zukunft ist das Thema Staats-
und verwaltungsdigitalisierung und
Monitor
Modernisierung so das teilen wir dieses
Anliegen in dieser Strategie findet man
kaum mehr etwas davon sie sagen wir
brauchen eine Eid teilen wir machen Sie
sie haben uns an ihrer Seite aber bei
allen anderen Themen der Staats- und
Verwaltungs Modernisierung machen sie
das weiter was wir vorgelegt haben es
gibt kaum neue Impulse im Gegenteil es
droht sogar ein Rückschritt denn lieber
Kollege Funke Kaiser wo sind denn die
Milliarden für die online für das
online-zugangsgesetz wir haben da
vorgelegt wir haben da jetzt was
aufgesetzt mit den Ländern dass wir alle
Verwaltungsdienstleistungen von vielen
Ländern und Kommunen digitalisieren und
wenn es da jetzt in den nächsten
Schritte gehen soll dann braucht es auch
eine Folgefinanzierung sonst steht das
Projekt sonst ruht das Projekt und ich
hoffe dass der digitalminister sich für
diese Themen dann genauso einsetzt wie
für Milliarden im Verkehrsbereich denn
sonst kann er das Thema digitalminister
an den Haken hängen dann ist ein erster
Linie Verkehrsminister das Thema
Modernisierung und Digitalisierung des
Staates all das was sie eben auch
versprochen haben was die Menschen
spüren sollen in unserem Land braucht
eine finanzielle und erfütterung und
braucht auch den politischen Willen
dieser Regierung das zusammen mit
Ländern und Kommunen umzusetzen und
davon ist in dieser Strategie nichts zu
finden
und ich will noch ein Wort zum Gigabit
Ausbaus sagen jetzt sagt der Minister
hier nach einem Jahr also das lief jetzt
super mit dem Ausbau vor Ort
wer ist dafür verantwortlich beruht das
etwa auf ihrem Handeln als
digitalminister sie haben noch überhaupt
nichts geändert beim Thema
gigabit-ausbau sie haben vor einem
halben Jahr eine Strategie vorgelegt
aber am Montag in der Anhörung hat man
uns bestätigt dass sie an fundamentalen
Änderungen noch überhaupt nichts gemacht
haben deshalb ist der Ausbau der jetzt
gerade passiert
berührt auf dem was wir was die
Vorgängerregierung gemacht hat
und jetzt haben sie eine neue Chance der
Minister hat gesagt er will einen vor
für alternative alternative
verlegemethoden wo ist das Konzept wo
ist die Finanzierung wo ist dieser vor
ich sehe ihn nicht der Minister hat als
zweites Schlüsselthema genannt ein
schnelleren Ausbau eines schnellere
Planungsprozesse eine
Genehmigungsfiktion die finden wir schon
gar nicht mehr in dieser
digitalstrategie und beim Thema
planungsbeschleunigung zeigt der
Minister mit dem Finger auf die Länder
und sagt das müssen die doch
also von all dem was in den ersten Tagen
versprochen worden ist noch nichts
umgesetzt all das was jetzt an Ausbau
erfolgt geduscht auf den Gesetzen die
wir vorgelegt hatten haben und wir
erwarten dass wenn sie wirklich hier
einen Fortschritt haben wollen wenn Sie
eine Modernisierung haben wollen wenn
Sie den digitalen Aufbruch machen wollen
den Sie hier versprechen dass in all den
Punkten mehr Tempo gewinnen dass in all
diesen Punkten die Finanzierungs sichern
und dass sie sich vor allem als
digitalminister darum kümmern dass das
Monitoring passiert und das jedes Haus
eine Hausaufgaben macht das können wir
noch nicht erkennen wir werden genau
schauen und sie auch gerne dabei
unterstützen denn uns liegt auch der
digitale Aufbruch sehr am Herzen
Nadine schön stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende für diesen Bereich
der cdu/csu hier mit ihrer Kritik die
CDU CSU hat einen eigenen Antrag
eingebracht der fordert man ein
digitalministerium bündung von
Kompetenzen und mehr cybersicherheit in
der nächste Redner jetzt der Müller für
die SPD die Digitalisierung prägt unser
Alltagsleben Punkt
egal ob er für die Fahrt mit der Bahn
online ein Ticket buchen im Homeoffice
arbeiten oder uns auch auf sozialen
Media Plattformen vernetzen wir befinden
uns in einer Welt in der die
Digitalisierung nicht mehr wegzudenken
ist und wir verlassen uns auf Sie doch
an vielen Stellen hakt das mit der
Digitalisierung in Deutschland noch
angefangen bei unzureichenden
Mobilfunkversorgung sie kennen das
sicherlich von der ein oder anderen
Bahnstrecke bis hin zu dem Bürgerämtern
zu denen man immer noch persönlich gehen
muss um beispielsweise einen neuen
Personalausweis zu beantragen
die Ampelkoalition hat sich deshalb zum
Ziel gesetzt die Digitalisierung endlich
auf die Höhe der Zeit zu bringen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das Parlament
musste einige Zeit darauf warten aber
nun haben wir mit der digitalen und
gigabit-strategie zwei Vorlagen die die
wichtigsten Vorhaben in dieser
Legislaturperiode bündeln und einen
konkreten Weg aufzeigen wie unser Land
die chancenart Digitalisierung nutzen
kann mit der gigabit-strategie wird der
Ausbau vom Glasfaseranschlüssen
vorangetrieben und für schnelles
Internet bis an jedes Zuhause jede
Schule jedes Gewerbegebiet
sprichwörtlich bis eben an jede
Milchkanne gesorgt zudem stellen wir
sicher
zudem stellen wir sicher dass der
neueste Mobilfunkstandard egal ob die
Stadt oder auf dem Land bis sie im Jahr
2030 verfügbar sein wird in der
digitalstrategie hingegen finden sich
konkrete Vorhaben für alle Ministerien
die bis zum Jahr 2025 umgesetzt werden
sollen konkret und für alle Ministerien
es ist die digitalpolitische
Prioritätenliste dieser Legislatur dazu
gehört insbesondere die Digitalisierung
der Verwaltung Verwaltung wird nach
Umsetzung davor haben viel
serviceorientierter und damit nahe an
den Bedürfnissen der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger ausgerichtet sein so werden wir
beispielsweise dafür sorgen dass
Bürgerinnen und Bürger Informationen
Nachweise für
Verwaltungsdienstleistungen digital und
damit nur ein einziges Mal bereitstellen
müssen Personalausweis und Führerschein
der Minister sprach davon endlich
digital werden und rentenübersichten
beispielsweise elektronisch zur
Verfügung stehen
zur digitalstrategie gehört auch die
Digitalisierung unserer Infrastruktur
und natürlich auch der Schiene denn zum
Erreichen des deutschlandpaktes braucht
es neben der Sanierung dem Ausbau des
Schienennetzes eine flächendecke
flächendeckende digitale leit- und
Sicherungstechnik damit wir die
Kapazität auf dem Streckennetz erhöhen
können gleiches gilt auch für die
Mobilität auf der Höhe der Zeit auch
hier müssen wir in einem fairen Rahmen
mehr Daten zur Verfügung stellen um den
Weg für die Entwicklung neuer und vor
allem effizienterer Mobilitätslösungen
zu ebnen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
klar ist aber auch all die genannten
Vorhaben benötigen zur Umsetzung eine
entsprechende finanzielle Untersetzung
wenn wir als mit der Priorisierung
dieser Maßnahmen und digital ist besser
ernst meinen braucht es ein ein und das
vereinbarte digital Budget
Herr Minister kann man das so ein
bisschen lassen Sie uns das
digitalbudget gemeinsam und vor allem
schnell auf den Weg bringen meine Damen
und Herren
nun müssen sowohl die digitalstrategie
als auch die gigabit-strategie in die
Tat umgesetzt werden damit die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger dieses Landes
endlich Digitalisierung auf der höhere
Zeit nutzen können
nicht alles geht schnell nicht alles
geht auch mir schnell genug nicht alles
ist auch jetzt schon perfekt aber wir
haben endlich eine gute Grundlage Frau
schön die Basics schaffen wir jetzt
damit das was wir lange vergessen haben
nicht geschafft dann schaffen wir jetzt
eine gute Grundlage für den Aufbruch ins
digitale Zeit aber vielen Dank
Detlef Müller in der SPD wie er die
Region mit trägt mit einem wichtigen
Hinweis es steht nichts von Geld in der
ganzen Strategie und in den jetzigen
Zeiten und bei diesem wichtigen Thema
musste man dafür kämpfen dass das mit
Geld unterfüttert wird das hat er
zumindest den Minister geraten Barbara
Lenk jetzt für die AFD frau Präsidentin
sehr verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
sehr geehrter Herr Minister
endlich könnte man rufen endlich was
lange währt wird endlich gut oder etwa
doch nicht die Ampel hat vollmundig im
Koalitionsvertrag eine digitalstrategie
angekündigt und endlich hat das
Bundeskabinett während seiner Klausur
auf Schloss Meseberg nun tatsächlich so
etwas wie eine digitalstrategie
verabschiedet
die Antwort auf die Frage was genau
eigentlich Digitalisierung ist erhält
man beim Lesen der digitalen Strategie
nicht
hier hat man so schön klingende
Schlagworte wie glasfaser-infrastruktur
digitale Identitäten oder ki-leuchttürme
dieses Potpourri an Elementen macht aber
noch keine echte digitalstrategie aus
und was genau meine Damen und Herren ist
in eine feministische digitalpolitik
aber kommen wir wieder zu ihrer Vorlage
die einzelnen Ressorts behalten weiter
ihre digitalkompetenzen ein Gerangel um
Zuständigkeiten ist somit doch weiterhin
wahrscheinlich
und das digitalministerium fehlt noch
immer
[Musik]
es ist durchaus positiv anzumerken dass
sich die Koalition bis Ende der 20
Legislatur an bestimmten Punkten zum
Erreichen der Ziele messen lassen will
zum Teil werden hier schon harte Zahlen
genannt beispielsweise sollen mindestens
80 Prozent der gesetzlich
Krankenversicherten über eine
elektronische Patientenakte verfügen zum
Teil bleiben die Kriterien jedoch sehr
schwammig meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren vieles aber bei dieser Strategie
bleibt niveaulos so schreibt die
Koalition
aufbauend auf Smart City und smart
Redens Modellprojekten ermöglichen wir
digitale Lösungen für bessere
Visualisierung von
Planungsentscheidungen leider wird hier
nicht weiter gedacht in Richtung einer
kohärten Smart Cities Strategie welche
eine digitale Verwaltung mit einschließt
dies wurde von unserer Fraktion bereits
in der letzten Legislatur gefordert
in vielen Sätzen meine Damen und Herren
lese ich das Wörtchen soll
das Fest für mich den Schluss zu dass so
manche Maßnahmen der digitalstrategie
vielleicht unter Finanzierungsvorbehalt
steht ist das vielleicht ein Grund dafür
dass auf über 50 Seiten kaum konkrete
Projekte mit Verantwortlichkeiten
aufgelistet werden und auch das
digitalbudget fehlt immer noch
und schließlich bei Monitoring der
vorliegenden digitalstrategie soll der
digitalrat eine beratende Rolle
wahrnehmen
während es nicht besser dieses
scheintote Gremium endlich aufzulösen
und damit das Kompetenz für war bei der
digitalpolitik ein wenig zu lichten
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen außer
Spesen nichts gewesen eine kohärente
digitalstrategie können wir als
afd-fraktion jedenfalls nicht erkennen
es ist positiv dass ein Anfang gemacht
ist aber das ganze Konstrukt muss nun
mit Leben gefüllt werden wenn
Deutschland
konkurrenzfähig bleiben soll besten Dank
Barbara Lenk für die AFD kritisierte
unter anderem dass es kein
digitalministerium gibt das kritisiert
auch die cdu/csu ja und das mit der
feministischen digitalpolitik sei mal
dahingestellt Mike außendorf jetzt der
digitalpolitische Sprecher der
bündnisgründen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen mit der
digital- und gigabit-strategie sind für
einen großen Schritt nach vorne gekommen
jetzt kann es losgehen mit der
Digitalisierung der Gesellschaft an der
Stelle gestatten sie bei Herr Minister
Wissing doch eine kleine kritische
Anmerkung wir haben in den Prozess immer
wieder angemerkt dass für die
Digitalisierung der Gesellschaft wir
auch die Zivilgesellschaft und die
Verbände einbindet einbinden müssen das
werden wir auch weiter fordern und Frau
Kahn wir gleich vorstellen wie wir uns
das vorstellen aber jetzt kommen wir zu
den positiven Dingen es ist wirklich
eine Strategie und wenn wir uns
anschauen welche drei hebelprojekte
benannt sind dann sehen wir auch warum
es im Namen Strategie verdient weil wir
nämlich hier gucken was müssen wir
zuerst tun um dann die Potenziale zu
heben und da möchte ich einige wichtige
Punkte nennen das ist zunächst die
elektronische Identität also die
Weiterentwicklung des elektronischen
Personalausweises damit sich Bürgerinnen
und Bürger online sicher zertifizieren
können und Geschäfts-
wir haben dann das Konzept zu
Nutzbarmachung der Daten das ist das
Stichwort dateninstitut damit die
Datenmengen die in vielen Unternehmen in
Einrichtungen auch in Regierungsstellen
schlummern genutzt werden können und
zwar sicher und anonymisiert zu
Entwicklung neuer Geschäftsmodelle von
Start-ups von Forschung von kleinen
Firmen und vor allen Dingen Richtung
Nachhaltigkeit denn das ist der weitere
große Punkt der für uns hervorzuheben
ist digitale Nachhaltigkeit das
umweltdatenportal ist auf unsere
Initiative hineingekommen in die
Strategie und an dem Punkt werden wir
Grüne weiterarbeiten damit wir eben die
Potenziale wirklich nutzen können um die
digitale Transformation Richtung
Nachhaltigkeit und Klimaneutralität
weiterzuentwickeln
was ist aber die Grundlage für all die
Konzepte die in der in der digitalen
Strategie genannt ist das sind
leistungsfähige Netze und was wir
wirklich brauchen ist schnelles Internet
in jedem Haus und an jeder Milchkanne
der nur so schaffen wir die
Voraussetzungen für intelligente
Lösungen wie zum Beispiel digitale
Rufbusse die per App geruft werden
können um im vorstädtischen Raum und im
ländlichen Raum die Mobilität zu
verbessern oder automatisierte
Bewässerung die in der Landwirtschaft
bei Auswertung von Wetter und bodendaten
den Ressourceneinsatz effizienter
gestaltet so und bei der
hergabestrategie da stimmt wirklich
alles es sind viele grüne Akzente
reingekommen der Vorgang für
unterversorgte Gebiete ist ganz wichtig
und Frau schön jetzt muss ich noch mal
auf Sie zurückkommen sie haben ja gesagt
dass sei ein Ergebnis ihrer Arbeit das
ist aber auch das Ergebnis dass wir
weiße Flecken im Mobilfunk auf dem Land
haben nämlich weil der Scheuer und die
Union die Frequenzvergabe so gestaltet
haben dass die Unternehmen nicht in der
Pflicht sind flächendeckend auszubauen
und deswegen brauchen wir jetzt auch
noch eine staatlichen Mobilfunk
Infrastrukturgesellschaft
mit ja wir uns jetzt rumschlagen müssen
also darf Frau schön haben sie wirklich
ein Eigentor geschossen so dann ganz
wichtig digitalbudget das haben wir im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart das muss
jetzt wirklich kommen damit wir loslegen
können die Zuständigkeiten sind geklärt
endlich muss ich sagen das ist gut wir
können jetzt also die Zukunftsprojekte
Digitalisierung aufnehmen und das möchte
ich auch noch sagen Digitalisierung ist
ja kein Selbstzweck wir setzen
Digitalisierung intelligent ein für
Erleichterung im digitalen und analogen
Alltag der Menschen und für die
Transformation hin zu einer nachhaltigen
und klimaneutralen Gesellschaft
mike außendorf ist der digitalpolitische
Sprecher der bündnisgründer Teil der
Bundesregierung sind und es war eine
bemerkenswerte Rede denn er begann diese
Rede mit einer Kritik an dem
ftp-minister die Digitalisierung er
sollte da die gesellschaftlichen
Gruppierungen mehr einbringen Anke
Domstadt Berg für die Linksfraktion sie
ist die Sprecherin für digitalpolitik
ihrer Fraktion
sehr geehrte Präsidentin liebe
kolikinnen meine letzte Rede hier
schloss ich mit folgendem Fazit zur
digitalstrategie sie enthält keine
Vision die beschreibt was man mit ihr
eigentlich erreichen will aber dafür
viele schwammige Ziele
Verantwortung bleibt weiterhin völlig
konfus verteilt und ihr fehlen immer
noch Ressourcen denn das digitalbudget
gibt es ja noch nicht vor allem aber
beantwortet sie die Frage nicht was will
man denn konkret jetzt eigentlich anders
machen als die Gokus vorher die ja auch
schöne Ziele formulierten aber nie
erreichten am Ende geht es nämlich
umzusetzen was man verspricht und da
habe ich meine Zweifel die Beteiligung
der Zivilgesellschaft fand nämlich trotz
Koalitionsvertrag Versprechen nicht
statt wie meine schriftliche Frage ergab
auf die digitalstrategie mit dem wohl
nicht zufällig wirtschaftsfreundlichen
Titel digitale Werte schöpfen nahmen 18
mal Lobbyisten der Wirtschaft Einfluss
darunter allein drei Lobbyisten verbannt
dagegen gab es kein einziges Gespräch
mit der digitalen Zivilgesellschaft von
Chaos Computerclub des Wikimedia und
erst recht nicht mit der sonstigen
Zivilgesellschaft zum Beispiel Senioren
Behinderten sozial oder
Verbraucherschutzverbänden das zeigt
wesseninteressen diese digitalstrategie
tatsächlich vertreten soll und das ist
ein unerträglicher Zustand meine Damen
und Herren
auch die gigabit-strategie ist ein
wirtschaftslobbyismus Papier von der
ersten bis zur letzten Seite der Markt
soll alles richten auch wenn genau
dieser Markt aus Deutschland ein Land
des lahmen Internets und der Funklöcher
gemacht hat und laut der
gigabit-strategie Minister Wissing
führte die bisherige Regulierung zu
einem funktionierenden Infrastruktur und
Dienste Wettbewerb ich lade Sie sehr
gern mal in die Ostprignitz ein da
stehen nämlich Funklöcher an Wettbewerb
miteinander und nicht Diensteanbietern
überhaupt
Wettbewerb auf infrastrukturebene das
ist so ziemlich das Dümmste was man
machen kann niemand niemand würde sich
mehrere Abwasserkanäle oder
Gasanschlüsse in ein Haus legen aber bei
Glasfaser soll so was Sinn machen es
gibt nicht genug tiefbaukapazitäten und
Fachkräfte aber diese Giga wird
Strategie toleriert dass wir weiter
mehrfach eine Straße aufreißen und
manche Orts zwei Glasfaser nebeneinander
zu legen obwohl das Dorfleben an immer
noch gar nichts hat nicht einmal wo eine
Kommune ein völlig offenes Glasfasernetz
verlegt hat dass maximale
wettbewerbsfreiheit bietet will diese
Bundesregierung den Überbau untersagen
sie spielt auf Zeit und will erstmal
2023 den Überbau evaluieren die gleiche
gigabit-strategie behauptet aber man
will Ressourcen sparen
Infrastrukturausbau das ist Greenwashing
und das lassen wir ihn nicht durchgehen
mit dieser gigabit-strategie macht sich
die Bundesregierung auch zum
Vertriebsmitarbeiter für große
telco-konzerne eine info-kampagne soll
es geben zur Anregung der Nachfrage nach
gigabit-netzen Zitate aus der Strategie
Gutscheine soll es geben zur Anregung
der Nachfrage nach inhouse Verkabelung
ein 215 Millionen schweres 5g
Innovationsprogramm soll die Nachfrage
von Kommunen und Unternehmen anregen und
die Ampel will digitalmanager ein
Landkreisen bezahlen die man ahnt es
nachfrageanregen soll und 5g Vorhaben in
ihren Landkreisen initiieren soll ich
sag mal was das heißt diese
digitalmanager werden mit Steuergeld
dafür bezahlt Aufträge für Konzerne zu
beschaffen die mit Steuergeld von den
Kommunen bezahlt werden das ist ein Fall
für die heute-show meine Damen und
Herren
völlig irre wird es aber im Abschnitt
Evaluation der Fördermaßnahmen ergibt
sie nämlich das vor 2030 das Ziel
gigabit-anschlüsse für alle erreichbar
sein sollte nennt diese Ampel das
Überforderung und will den Ausbau sofort
Bremsen Bremsen mit antragsstopps und
Quotierungen der Förderungen denkt man
im bmdv auf ein paar Jahre mehr oder
weniger lahm ist Netz in der Ostprignitz
oder im Sauerland kommt es nicht an
Hauptsache bei Konzernen klingelt der
Geldbeutel lauter und länger das ist
Menschen und fortschrittsfeindliche
Politik und das wird die Linksfraktion
nicht unterstützen vielen Dank
angedummschalte Berg einen Punkt will
ich herausheben die tief
tiefbaukapazitäten und die Fachkräfte
hat sie angesprochen ein ganz wichtiger
Aspekt es gibt tatsächlich in
Deutschland viel zu wenig Firmen die
diese Kabel verlegen und an Fachkräften
fehlt es ohne hin Maximilian Funke
Kaiser jetzt für die FDP
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Bundesminister liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Liebe Union
ganz ehrlich bei der Lektüre Ihres
Antrags mit dem Titel und ich zitiere
Stillstand und zuständigkeitschaos und
der digitalpolitik beenden für eine
ambitionierte und koordinierte
digitalstrategie da musste ich schon ein
bisschen schmunzeln denn das hat denn
die Union die letzten eineinhalb
Jahrzehnte in diesem Bereich vorzuweisen
richtig rein gar nichts zugestanden
Scheinheiligkeit das können siehe den
Stillstand den haben allerdings sie zu
verantworten liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sie haben zig Strategien
verabschiedet sie haben sexstrategien
verabschiedet haben den zweiten Schritt
vor dem ersten Schritt gemacht sie haben
digitalpolitik in der digitalpolitik bei
jeder Wahl bundland Kommune den Menschen
das Blaue vom Himmel versprochen
übersetzt sie haben mit dem Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern 16 Jahre lang Bullshit
Schaufenster Bullshit Bingo gespielt
ohne die wirklich wichtigen Schritte in
diesem Land anzugehen und das hat mit
dieser digitalen Strategie jetzt ein
Ende weil wir machen jetzt Tempo
der liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
wollen die Digitalisierung voranbringen
und das machen wir auch mit dieser
digitalstrategie denn sie packt an den
Wurzeln des Problems an denn anders als
bisherige digitalstrategien ist die
nicht mehr ein reines Sammelsurium an
Einzelvorhaben sie ist eine Strategie
die an den Grundlagen anpackt Grundlagen
die wir eigentlich schon längst
gebraucht hätten und das sind diese drei
hebelprojekte Punkt eins wir brauchen
Highspeed Netz ist eigentlich traurig
dass wir das im Jahre 2022 überhaupt
noch da reinschreiben müssen ohne
schnelles Internet keine Digitalisierung
deswegen die gigabit-strategie wir
brauchen eine einheitliche
Dateninfrastruktur eine einheitliche
datenspare denn auch da ohne Daten keine
Digitalisierung und wir brauchen eine
sichere und nutzerfreundliche digitale
Identität denn sie ist das Tor für jeden
einzelnen Menschen in die digitale Welt
und was mir dabei wirklich sehr sehr
wichtig ist das wurde auch schon gesagt
das ist alles kein Selbstwert wir machen
das um den Wohlstand von morgen zu
sichern wir machen das um nachhaltig zu
werden wir machen das um den Menschen in
diesem Land das Leben zu erleichtern und
machen wir uns nichts vor durch die
Pandemie und durch den ukrainekrieg
müssen jetzt Entscheidungen für die
Zukunft dieses Landes getroffen werden
und dabei geht es auch um
Standortbedingungen und
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit in diesem Land denn
ja wir erleben eine Zeitenwende und
genau in einer solchen Zeit brauchen wir
eine Neubegründung unseres Landes
effiziente Verwaltung moderne
Gesundheitsversorgung leistungsfähige
Infrastruktur das digitale wird diese
Neubegründung ermöglichen warum weil wir
Zeit sparen weil wir Geld sparen und
weil wir auch dazu noch den Klimaschutz
beispielsweise ermöglichen das kann und
das wird das neue Geschäftsmodell für
den Wohlstand unserer Generation von
morgen und es ist unsere Pflicht dass
wir das jetzt machen denn am Ende geht
es um deine Erfolg der nachfolgenden
Generationen dafür steht diese Strategie
und dafür die Politik der Freien
Demokraten herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
DR reinhard Brandl
frau Präsidentin verehrte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen liebe Herr Funke Kaiser in
welcher Welt leben sie überhaupt welches
Dokument haben Sie denn gelesen das was
sie jetzt gerade angesprochen haben
nämlich die digitalstrategie ist doch
genau das es ist keine Strategie sondern
es ist ein Sammelsurium an
Einzelprojekten die weitgehend
zusammenhangslos sind und wissen Sie
wie ein solches Dokument entsteht das
kann ich Ihnen genau beschreiben man
fragt alle Ressorts ab und sagt bitte
nennt mir eure drei populärsten Projekte
und dann kopiert man den Rücklauf
zusammen und setzt ein paar
Überschriften drüben aber ein richtiger
digitalminister muss mehr leisten als
copy-pace
und Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Herr Funke Kaiser Herr Funke Kaiser sie
haben gesagt wir gehen nicht an den
Ursachen
das wichtigste für die digitalstrategie
wäre doch dass man sich mal überlegt
woran der vielen öffentlichen
Digitalisierungsprojekte in der
Vergangenheit gescheitert sind und es
lag nicht daran dass die FDP nicht
regiert hat es lag nicht einen guten
Ideen die gab schon vorher es lag auch
nicht am Geld und an den Mitarbeiter
sondern es lag es lag an nicht
getroffenen Entscheidungen und es lag an
unklaren Rahmenbedingungen und mit
dieser Strategie entscheiden Sie
original nichts weil wir würden denn
gern wissen wo steht denn die Ampel zum
Beispiel im Spannungsfeld Freiheit und
Sicherheit wie halten Sie es denn mit
dem Föderalismus wir wissen doch genau
wir wissen alle dass er Föderalismus so
sehr wie ihr ihn lieben mit einer der
Hauptursachen ist warum die
verwaltungsdigitalisierung in vielen
Bereichen nicht funktioniert wir wollen
Sie denn mit den großen
internetkonzernen umgehen Google
Microsoft Amazon das ist doch der große
elef der weiße Elefant im Raum wollen
sie kooperieren oder wollen Sie sich
unabhängig machen all das sind
ungeklärte Richtungsentscheidungen die
uns die Regierung
getroffen hat und ich halte das
verantwortungslos sie hatten jetzt in
Meseberg die Chance ein Paket zu bilden
all diese Entscheidungen auf einmal zu
treffen und ehrlich gesagt wäre schon
fast egal wie sie entscheiden hauptsache
sie würden entscheiden weil dann hätte
man nämlich eine Richtung und mit der
Richtung könnten alle mal loslaufen aber
mit ihrer Strategie in der Hand Herr
Wissing läuft doch keiner los weil hat
er nicht mal Geld dabei ist ja gar nicht
klar ob es finanziert wird und meine
Damen und Herren meine Damen und Herren
sie hatten im Koalitionsvertrag eine
gute Idee nämlich den das digitalbudget
aber es steht nicht im Haushalt der 2022
und es steht nicht im Haushalt für 2023
wann wollen Sie dann mit anfangen wenn
die Wahl vorbei ist wir haben es
beantragt sie haben es abgelehnt und
wissen Sie die genaue Begründung
sie können sich nicht einigen wer was
bekommt es heißt aber das sind Summe
niemand etwas bekommt und so kommt die
Digitalisierung in Deutschland auch
nicht voran
und was mich wirklich
was mich wirklich besorgt ist dass sie
die größte das größte Risiko für die
Digitalisierung in Deutschland mit
keinem Wort erwähnen
99 Prozent der modernen sieben
nanometer-chips kommen heute aus Taiwan
und aus Südkorea wenn diese Lieferkette
einmal abreißt dann kommt kein neuer
Computer mehr in Deutschland an dann
läuft kein Auto mehr vom Band und auch
sonst wird noch viel mehr nichts mehr
produziert und meine Damen und Herren
ist es richtig es ist gut dass Intel im
Magdeburg investiert aber das alleine
reicht nicht wir müssen die gesamten
Wertschöpfungsketten im
Halbleiterbereich in den Blick nehmen
und davon sehe ich und höre ich von der
Ampel original gar nichts weder von
Herrn Wissing noch von Herrn
wird sich jetzt auf der Regierungsbank
wahrscheinlich denken wovon redet dieser
Brandl überhaupt
ich
bin doch ich bin dafür Chips gar nicht
zuständige bautische und die Straße nach
Magdeburg aber das Problem herrlich das
stimmt in Wirklichkeit sind sehr für
fast nichts zuständig wir haben es mal
ausgewertet 18 Prozent der Aufgaben im
Bereich Digitalisierung sind in ihrem
Haus ich sag's mal vorsichtig mit einem
Projekt 18 hat die FDP keine gute
Erfahrung in der Vergangenheit
ich hoffe mal das ist kein
kein schlechtes Omen denn wir brauchen
eigentlich einen starken digitalminister
wir brauchen eine echte digitalstrategie
und wir brauchen endlich
Richtungsentscheidungen in der
Digitalisierung weil so wie sie arbeiten
so wird es nichts
sagte reinhard Brandl der
digitalpolitische Sprecher der CDU CSU
er warf dem Bundesminister vorher was er
vorgelegt habe seinen Sammelsurium ein
Einzelprojekt in der Tat ist Teil der
Strategie sind 19 sogenannte
Leuchtturmprojekte Jens Zimmermann jetzt
der digitalpolitische Sprecher der
SPD-Fraktion sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen zu Beginn dieser
Legislaturperiode habe ich hier gesagt
wir wollen es nicht nur besser machen
wir müssen es auch anders machen und ich
glaube die Rede vom Kollegen Brandl hat
es eben noch mal eindrucksvoll unter
Beweis gestellt warum das dringend
notwendig ist liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
unsere Strategie mit der wollen wir
Sicherheit in dieser schwierigen Zeit
des Wandels der ja an vielen vielen
Stellen uns momentan beschäftigt
schaffen und ich finde das machen wir
auch denn dazu gehört natürlich da sind
sich alle Rednerinnen und Redner hier
einig ein digitale Aufbruch und der
braucht eben
Aufbruch bei der Infrastruktur das ist
das was mein Kollege Detlef Müller
gesagt hat das sind unsere Hausaufgaben
da gibt es überhaupt keine Diskussionen
drüber und wir brauchen aber auch ein
schönes neues Wort das dieser Tage
überall genannt wird wir brauchen
Resilienz das heißt wir müssen unsere
Gesellschaft digital fest und sicher
machen gerade in Zeiten dieser Konflikte
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und ja diese Strategie ist kein
Sammelsurium von Wolkenkuckucksheim
sondern wir haben ganz klare
Themenfelder identifiziert wo wir gesagt
haben da müssen wir Prioritäten setzen
denn da ist die große Hebelwirkung drin
und ich will nur mal drei nennen das ist
das Thema natürlich digitale
Infrastruktur ich habe keine Lust mehr
wenn ich Freitags hier aus Berlin mit
dem Zug rausfahre dass an der
Stadtgrenze Berlin der Mobilfunk
abbricht da sind wir uns auch alle einig
aber es muss eben jetzt auch erledigt
werden liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wir haben das Thema öffentliche
Verwaltung Digitalisierung der
Verwaltung da haben wir das Thema der
digitalen Identität definiert und das
ist ja leider ein Projekt wo wir in der
vergangenen Legislaturperiode den
richtigen Impuls aus dem Kanzleramt
hatten aber leider am Ende das Ding
unbedingt noch vor der Bundestagswahl
gestartet werden musste und es war ein
weiterer rohrkrippierer leider muss ich
sagen von Andy scheuer und
als drittes Projekt mit Hebelwirkung das
ist dieser Tage glaube ich allen klar
ist wir müssen international standard
setzen denn gemeinsam mit vielen
Nationen auf der Welt so wie es auch der
Bundeskanzler diese Woche in New York
gemacht hat Verbündete zu suchen auch im
digitalen Raum das ist wichtiger denn je
und deswegen will diese Koalition und
wird diese Koalition ein Schwerpunkt bei
der internationalen Normen und
standardsetzung setzen das ist ganz
entscheidend gerade in diesen Zeiten
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und weil es eben diese Sicherheit im
Wandel braucht müssen wir unsere
Gesellschaft eben auch sicher machen
gegen die Feinde von außen wenn wir
sehen Cyberangriffe wir brauchen bei der
IT-Sicherheit mehr mehr Initiativen aber
es geht eben auch darum unsere
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu befähigen Fake
News zu erkennen immun zu werden gegen
Manipulation von außen und wie
problematisch das ist das sehen wir doch
wenn wir hören das Putin 300 Millionen
Euro investiert hat um Demokratien in
Europa zu destabilisieren und wenn ich
mir die Wahlen in Italien gerade
anschaue was da online alles passiert
dann wird es doch deutlich um was es da
geht in Italien und da wird mir schlecht
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
da wird mir schlecht wenn ich dann
Manfred Weber den
oberkonservativen aus dem Europäischen
Parlament an der Seite von Silvio
Berlusconi und den Postfaschisten sehe
das kann doch nicht sein liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen dann müssen Sie
doch auch mal dazu was sagen
und genau das ist eben auch Teil unserer
digitalstrategie weil warum macht man
denn so was warum trifft sich denn der
Berlusconi mit den Manfred Weber damit
er es am Ende digital einsetzen kann um
seiner eigenen Bevölkerung weiß zu
machen die Freunde Putins die in Italien
an die Macht wollen das sind eigentlich
ganz normale konservative da wäre Alice
Weidel der linke Flügel in dieser Partei
meine Damen und Herren und da sind sie
zu Recht sprachlos herzlichen Dank
Jens Zimmermann war das der Bundestag
der debattiert seit heute morgen um 9
über die digital und gigabak mit
Strategie der Bundesregierung vorgelegt
vom zuständigen Minister Wissing und
jetzt Eugen Schmidt für die AFD
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidenten
mit Tiere Erlaubnis zitiere ich aus der
digitalstrategie der Bundesregierung wir
wollen breitbeinige
mobilkommunikationssysteme zu jeder Zeit
an jedem Ort und Glasfaser bis zum
Hausanschluss flächendeckend 2010
das war ein Zitat aus dem
Aktionsprogramm der Bundesregierung von
jetzt will man dasselbe plötzlich erst
2030 schaffen ja sie hatte Bürger 22
Jahre später fällt diese Regierung ein
dass sie noch 20 Jahre länger braucht
dieselbe und seriöse Regierung die Ihnen
durch Tipps geben will
ich frage sie von der Regierung wieso
sollen die Bürger ihren Plänen
ausgerechnet jetzt glauben schenken
wieso Benehmen sie nicht die Gründe für
die Verzögerung
kein Wort dazu in ihrem Papierchen
dann ihr wir es Gerede von digitaler
Souveränität ohne überhaupt zu sagen von
wem sie sich unabhängig machen wollen
sie trauen sich richtig her die USA oder
China zu erwähnen
2018 wollten sie Deutschland noch zum
Leitmarkt für 5g entwickeln
haben sie sich mal gefragt warum sie mit
ihrem geduldigen Papieren ständig
scheitern
die zentrale Frage ist die von Bildung
des eigenen Volkes sie sprechen selbst
von Ausbau von Kompetenzen in
Schlüsseltechnologien aber
Mikrochips KI und Quantenrechner lernt
man nicht in inklusiven für menisismus
genderseminar
sie betreiben die aus plunderung von
Leistungsträgern und für untreuung von
Steuergeld an Gender tulias und
politaugend nicht in Stadt und enjios
sie betreiben die Massenzuwanderung von
Analphabeten also sind sie auch direkt
für den Rückschnitt verantwortlich
in den in den deutschen steckt
unglaubliches Potenzial sie von der
Regierung machen das nicht
ihr gefahren von Chancengerechtigkeit
führt eben nicht zu einer Zitat
spitzenrolle im Weltlauf
sondern zum technischen Niveau der
schrottampel mit drei Lämpchen und vier
Transistoren
Deutschland wird auch nicht erfolgreich
wenn wir Chinas total überwachen
kopieren wie sie das ja Vorhaben
erfolgreich sind wir dann wenn wir unser
eigenes Volk aktivieren warum sollten
qualifizierte deutsche überhaupt im Land
bleiben wenn Heimat Herkunft und folgt
doch beliebig sind ich sage ihnen ihr
Plan wird scheitern
danke
ja ich weiß nicht sie haben es
wahrscheinlich nicht gesehen Volker
Wissing hat den Kopf geschüttelt
ausgerechnet dem liberalen eine
Totalüberwachung des deutschen Volkes
als Ziel vorzuwerfen ist in der Tat
gewagt missbarkan jetzt der
die nächste Rednerin hier ist im
Ausschuss für digitales von den
bündnisgründen
Absichtserklärung gab es in der
Vergangenheit eigentlich schon genug und
eigentlich
steht im Koalitionsvertrag auch schon
alles zumindest fast alles was wir für
richtig halten aber gut wenn wir jetzt
eine digitalstrategie brauchen damit
sich Deutschland von seinen Faxgeräten
verabschiedet dann sei dem ebenso
digitalpolitik ist Gesellschaftspolitik
und mit welchen Prioritäten wir in den
nächsten Jahren eben diese
digitalpolitik gestalten macht einen
relevanten Unterschied dabei
wer davon profitiert und Frau Lenk wenn
sie jetzt aufpassen dann lernen Sie
etwas
[Applaus]
es macht nämlich ein relevanten
Unterschied vorhandene macht
Ungleichheit die in dieser Gesellschaft
existiert und die von einigen hier in
dem Haus auch wem man verteidigt wird
die gibt es und es macht es macht dann
einen Unterschied wenn wir erkennen dass
es eine Gefahr ist dass diese Macht und
Gleichheit besteht wir müssen also
unsere digitalpolitik gerechter machen
wir müssen sie barrierefreier mal machen
und wir müssen sie
gemeinwohlorientierter machen uns geht
es um den Schutz von marginalisierten
Gruppen uns geht es um Grundrechte und
Menschenrechte und gibt es uns
Nachhaltigkeit uns geht es um
Sozialpolitik und uns geht es eben auch
um eine intersekten intersektionalen
Feminismus
du hast gerade Demokratie erwähnt ja
auch darum geht es uns denn
Digitalisierung erschöpft sich für uns
nicht bei der Frage um schnelles
Internet wenn es um unseren Kern geht
dann geht es um unsere demokratischen
Grundwerte die wir auch in der digitalen
Welt verteidigen wollen
und deshalb muss unsere digitalpolitik
zwingend eine intersektionale und eine
feministische digitalpolitik sein
unsere Welt ist auch zu komplex für
quickfixes zu oft schauen wir auf ein
gesellschaftliches Problem und Glauben
mit einer coolen App oder mit mehr
Überwachung wird alles gut aber das ist
nur Symptombekämpfung und es ist
technologische fleckshusterei
stattdessen brauchen wir eine
digitalpolitik die die
gesamtgesellschaftlichen Auswirkungen in
den Blick nimmt und eben dieser Fokus
macht einen relevanten Unterschied wenn
wir zum Beispiel diskutieren über die
chatkontrolle oder über digitale
Identitäten und darum geht es uns wenn
wir von einer intersektionalen an einer
feministischen digitalpolitik sprechen
dass die Idee der dass die Idee der
feministischen digitalpolitik jetzt in
der digitalstrategie verankert ist ist
deshalb richtig und wichtig und ein
relevanter Anfang aber dabei kann es
nicht bleiben was wir jetzt brauchen ist
eine konsequente Zusammenarbeit mit der
digitalen Zivilgesellschaft die viel zu
oft in der letzten Zeit vergessen wurde
in der Vergangenheit haben wir Millionen
Steuergelder für Projekte ausgegeben die
dann nach wenigen Tagen gescheitert sind
deshalb werden wir in dieser Koalition
endlich die Expertise ernst nehmen und
auf sie hören denn anders als in der
Vergangenheit wollen wir uns nicht zu
fein sein zum eigenen Schaden richtige
Hinweise anzunehmen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
liebe Kollegin Kahn ich wollte hier in
Redefluss nicht unterbrechen aber wenn
sie mich beim nächsten Mal begrüßen zu
Beginn der Rede wäre ich sehr dankbar
nächster Redner für die SPD-Fraktion
Johannes Schätzel
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen die
gigabit-strategie der Bundesregierung
ist die erste ganzheitliche Strategie
die sich mit dem Infrastrukturausbau in
unserem Land beschäftigt diese Strategie
sie wurde über Wochen in
vertrauensvoller Zusammenarbeit erstellt
und sehr geehrter Herr Minister ich muss
an dieser Stelle sagen ich finde sie
sehr gelungen Herr Minister
sie haben es aber auch angesprochen wir
brauchen diese Strategie weil es kaum
ein Thema gibt dass wir über so viele
Jahre immer und immer wieder gleich
diskutieren ein Thema bei dem wir uns
eigentlich alle in der Zielsetzung
vollkommen einig sind und dennoch ein
Thema bei dem wir gemessen an unseren
eigenen Zielen nicht schnell genug
Vorankommen es geht um ungehaltene
Versprechungen es geht auch um einen
Flicken Teppich von Förderungen und das
wichtigste es wurde jahrelang auf die
falsche Technologie gesetzt Kupfer statt
Glasfaser vergoldete koaxialnetze die
Anbieter hat das zwar gefreut
Deutschland aber nicht
Liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen wir ändern
das die gigabit-strategie setzt auf auf
den Koalitionsvertrag der
Koalitionsvertrag besagt Glasfaser in
jedes Haus Glasfaser in jede Wohnung wir
haben verstanden dass es die Glasfaser
braucht um die Datenmengen von morgen zu
transportieren die
gigabit-gesellschaft meine Damen meine
Herren darf im Jahr 2022 keine leere
Worthülse mehr sein moderne Arbeiten
moderne Produktion wir brauchen Gigabit
fähige Netze und deswegen steht unser
Ziel bis 2025 wollen wir 50% der
Haushalte mit
Glasfaseranschluss versorgt haben und
danach geht es weiter
Liebe Union ein Wort zu ihrem Antrag sie
haben einen Antrag gestellt und sie
fordern jetzt jetzt fordern sie 15
Milliarden für den digitalen
Infrastrukturausbau und sie fordern
dabei ich zitiere aus ihrem Antrag
Gigabit Netze bereitstellen sowie den
Glasfaserausbau voranbringen ich finde
es schwierig dass wir wieder von so wie
sprechen wir haben jahrelang den
gleichen Fehler gemacht Kupfer und
koaxial zu fördern jetzt wieder beides
da machen wir nicht mit das ist keine
gute Idee
und damit wir unsere Ziele tatsächlich
erreichen werden wir Tempo ins Verfahren
bekommen durch schlankere und digitale
Genehmigungsverfahren wir begegnen den
tiefbaukapazitäten mit alternativen
verlegemethoden und wir schaffen ein
Förderinstrument was auf der einen Seite
den Markt zu Tempo animiert und auf der
anderen Seite genau da einspringt wo es
notwendig ist wir sprechen von
Potenzialanalysen wir sprechen von
Abstimmungen mit privaten Kapitalgebern
wir sprechen an dieser Stelle von
Dutzenden von Maßnahmen die am Ende
zusammenpassen um unsere Ziele zu
erreichen
neben dem
Glasfaserausbau kümmert sich die
Gigabyte Strategie auch um das Thema
Mobilfunk Ziel ist und bleibt eine
flächendeckende Mobilfunkversorgung auch
mit dem neuesten Mobilfunkstandard dafür
setzen wir auf Bund länderabstimmungen
wir setzen auf vereinheitlichte Vorgaben
auf einem klaren Rechtsrahmen und
genauso werden wir das Ziel erreichen 5g
in jeder Stadt 5g auf dem Land auf jeder
Autobahn und in jedem Zug genau dafür
ist dieses Papier gut und ich freue mich
auf die weitere Zusammenarbeit auf einen
Fortschritt in digitale Infrastruktur
vielen Dank
Johannes Schätzel vom Beruf Informatiker
hat hier gleich mal als erstes den
Minister gelobt da haben wir heute ja
auch schon anderes aus der Ampel gehört
und der hat hier noch mal dargestellt
dass es genau richtig ist Schritt für
Schritt bis zum Jahr 2025 50 Prozent
Glasfaser und dann bis zum Jahr 2030 und
so muss man es machen sagt Viertel Mark
wir das jetzt für die cocs
Digitalisierung zu nutzen ist zentral
für die soziale wirtschaftliche und
gesellschaftliche Teilhabe und eine
faire ökologische Transformation der
Gesellschaft diesen im Koalitionsvertrag
verankerten Grundgedanken spiegelt die
beschlossene
digitalstrategie bislang nur bedingt
wieder der Erfolg der digitalen
Strategie hängt nun stark von der
Umsetzung der beschlossenen Projekte ab
die Strategie lässt wichtige Punkte
weiter offen beispielsweise dass
digitalbudget das im Koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart wurde und bisher nicht im
Haushalt hinterlegt ist liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das sind leider
nicht meine Worte das ist die
Pressemitteilung der Grünen im Deutschen
Bundestag
wir sind uns wohl alle einig liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen dass sie in der
Opposition wohl besser aufgehoben waren
das Problem ist aber sie regieren jetzt
ihre vorgelegte digitalstrategie steht
exemplarisch für die Arbeit der Ampel
Bundesregierung in den ersten neun
Monaten sie starten mit großen
Ankündigungen von Aufbruch und
Fortschritt und verlieren sich dann in
koalitionsstreitereien über Ideologie
und Zuständigkeiten das ist nicht gut
meine Damen und Herren sie verabschieden
eine dachstrategie nach der anderen aber
unter dem Dach hängt der Haussegen Chef
regieren heißt Verantwortung zu
übernehmen und Herr Kollege Funke Kaiser
bitte kommen Sie nicht jetzt schon
wieder mit 16 Jahren der unionsgeführten
Bundesregierung das ist ihre
digitalstrategie das ist ihre Bilanz der
digitalpolitik
in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag schreiben Sie
Kompetenzen der Bundesregierung werden
neu geordnet und neu gebündelt doch
jetzt machen sie das glatte Gegenteil
für die datenstrategie ist das
Verkehrsministerium das
Wirtschaftsministerium und das
Innenministerium zuständig drei für das
zentrale Thema der digitalen Identitäten
ist das Innenministerium das
Bundeskanzleramt das Verkehrsministerium
das Finanzministerium und das
Wirtschaftsministerium 5 verantwortlich
wer blickt da noch durch
was ist jetzt braucht ist ein echtes
digitalministerium das auch wirklich mit
dem nötigen Rückhalt und der Kompetenz
der digitalpolitik vorantreibt wie wir
sind unserem Antrag von CDU und CSU
fordern weshalb das dringend nötig ist
zeigt auch das Arbeitsministerium von
Hubertus Heil Arbeitgebern wird verboten
Informationen zum Arbeitsverhältnis per
E-Mail statt per Post zu schicken und
auch die Flexibilisierung von
Arbeitszeiten hat das Arbeitsministerium
wieder aus der digitalstrategie
herausgestrichen so wird es nichts mit
dem digitalen Aufbruch liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen aber liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen zur ambitionslos die Ziele der
digitalstrategie auch sein mögen nicht
einmal diese werden sie umsetzen denn
die Lichter für die Leuchtturmprojekte
dieser digitale Strategie bleiben ohne
dass digital-budget leider aus wieso
haben sie ein solches digital-b
eigentlich nicht schon längst
vorgestellt liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Ampel wir als Union haben
schon vor Monaten in einem Antrag zum
Haushalt darauf hingewiesen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
machen in unserem Antrag 30 konkrete
Vorschläge für die Digitalisierung in
unserem Land ihre digitalstrategie
hingegen zeigt Bedenken first digital
second oder ob es oder um es mit den
Worten des digitalpolitischen Sprechers
der Grünen zu sagen die digitalstrategie
lässt Luft nach oben herzlichen Dank
nächster Redner für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen Tobias bacherle
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen dass die
Bundesregierung sich mit der
digitalstrategie so intensiv mit
digitalpolitik beschäftigt das ist gut
das ist notwendig schließlich haben wir
uns im Koalitionsvertrag einen
strammesprogramm vorgenommen was
notwendig war mussten wir um dieses Land
endlich zu modernisieren endlich fit für
die 20er Jahre dieses Jahrhunderts zu
machen ich will positiv bleiben Liebe
Union herzlichen Glückwunsch ich will
gratulieren dass sie sich in diesem
Antrag so gut die Lieblingsprojekte aus
digitalstrategie und Koalitionsvertrag
zusammengesucht haben und damit ja auch
die verpassten Chancen ihre
Regierungsarbeit so deutlich aufarbeiten
aber lieber mag biadacz eine Sache wir
sind da an der Stelle eben auch bereit
Manöverkritik zu üben während wir
regieren als Fraktion um eben noch
schneller und während der Regierungszeit
und nicht erst danach noch besser zu
werden
in unserer in unserer digital oder in
der digitalstrategie der Bundesregierung
stellen wir bei der Digitalisierung den
Menschen in den Mittelpunkt Menschen
müssen selbstbestimmt über Ihre Daten
bestimmen können und digital teilhaben
können und das ist keine Logik die an
unseren Außengrenzen ändern darf wir
wollen ja schließlich keine gläserne
Bürgerin mit Ihren Daten und ihren
Profil am Ende autoritären Regime auf
dem digitalen Silbertablet Servieren für
unsere Regierungspolitik ist ja auch der
zivilgesellschaftliche Austausch ganz
besonders wichtig und damit das eben
auch weltweit und in der Außenpolitik
funktionieren kann müssen wir Menschen
vor Zensur Überwachung oder auch
abgeschalteten Internet schützen und uns
international dafür einbringen
und gerade in den letzten Monaten sollte
allen klar geworden sein wie ein
notwendig es ist digitalpolitik global
und sicherheitspolitisch zu denken das
geht die Bundesregierung an dazu kurz
zwei Highlights mit der geplanten data
MBC datenausweis sitzt wie das dann im
Behörden Deutsch so schön heißt schaffen
wir einen digitalen Zwilling unserer
Regierungsdaten und dadurch Absicherung
und Beständigkeit für unser Handeln auch
in krassen Krisen und mit dem Engagement
bei Gothic ein Projekt welches
verwaltungsdigitalisierung weltweit
stärkt unterstützen wir die digitale
Souveränität von Menschen und die
Zugänge und Möglichkeiten von
Regierungen weltweit und ja ich bin mir
sicher dabei können auch wir noch was
von anderen lernen also die
technologische Entwicklung ist rasant
Innovation hält sich im Zweifel eben
nicht an Grenzen es ist also eine
Notwendigkeit digitalpolitik
international zu denken einfach weil
unsere ganze Welt eine digitale ist
und trotzdem müssen wir bei uns anfangen
überwachungsgesamtrechnung statt einer
absurden chatkontrolle
sicherheitslückenmanagement und eine
ordentliche Finanzierung für digitale
Projekte und unsere globale
Verantwortung müssen unser Beitrag sein
das ist dann die Grundlage worauf ich
mich freue aufbauend auf diesem Auftakt
eine internationale digitalstrategie
anzugehen für ein demokratisches offenes
partizipatives und selbstbestimmtes
Internet vielen Dank
Tobias bachale für die bündnisgrillen
der Bundestag die diskutiert über die
digital und gigabit-strategie der
Bundesregierung und die nächste die das
tut ist Carolin Wagner für die SPD
zwischen neue Orte zu erkunden lang
vermisste Freunde wiederzusehen günstig
zum Arbeitsplatz zu pendeln Mobilität
bewegt uns und mobilität ist ein
Zukunftsthema das gleiche gilt für die
Digitalisierung und zusammengenommen
heißt das in der Mobilität der Zukunft
spielen Daten eine entscheidende Rolle
und wie wir die Mobilität der Zukunft in
unsere Gegenwart holen das steht in der
digitalstrategie als eines der 18
Leuchtturmprojekte in der
digitalstrategie ist ein Ökosystem für
Mobilitätsdaten genannt dieses Ökosystem
für Mobilitätsdaten umfasst zum einen
den mobility data space der Anfang
dieses Jahres ans Netz gegangen ist mit
dem mobility data space stellen wir ein
technisches System bereit mit dem
Mobilitätsdaten fair geteilt werden
können das mag jetzt abstrakt klingen
aber dieser Datenraum birgt die
Grundlage für zahlreiche ganz konkrete
innovative Anwendung
zum Beispiel
zum Beispiel für neue
Mobilitätsdienstleistungen wie Apps die
individuell und standortbezogen anzeigen
wo in der Nähe ein E-Bike oder E-Roller
zur Verfügung stehen oder die den
eigenen Standort in einer fremden Stadt
einen Taxi melden dass man sich über
diese App ruft und ganz wichtig dabei im
mobility data space werden die
Eigentumsrechte der datenbesitzer:innen
an Ihren Daten gewahrt und
Datenschutzstandards geachtet und das
ist ein großer Unterschied zu den
intransparenten Datenspeicher Giganten
Google und Co denen wir mit ihren
haifischartigen Geschäftsmodellen dieses
Feld nicht konkurrenzlos überlassen
wollen nicht überlassen dürfen wird die
Kolleginnen
den anderen Teil dieses Ökosystems für
Mobilitätsdaten liefert die Mobilität
die Mobilität enthält Daten aus dem
öffentlichen Verkehr etwa Fahrpläne der
Bahn Echtzeitdaten aus dem ÖPNV aber
eben auch allgemeine Wetterdaten und nun
gilt es als nächsten Schritt beide
Plattformen erstens zu verknüpfen
zweitens weiterhin dafür zu sorgen sie
mit hochwertigen Daten zu befüllen und
sie drittens strategisch sinnvoll
weiterzuentwickeln und für den mobility
data space gilt ferner möglichst
vielfältige datengeber die
Automobilindustrie
leitbetriebssystembetreiber die Bahn
Busanbieter aber eben auch Kommunen und
so weiter für die Teilnahme zu gewinnen
und zu guter Letzt gilt es diesen
Datenraum nicht an den
landesgrenzenenden zu lassen sondern ihn
als europäischen Datenraum mit unseren
Nachbarländern zu verknüpfen und wenn
sie mir werte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Union jetzt immer noch sagen das
entspricht keiner Strategie dann
erinnert mich das eigentlich nur noch an
den Wunder
Pumuckl der sagt Weinen ist ja sehr
schön aber langweilig wenn es keiner
hört mit herzlichen Dank
Verknüpfung mit den europäischen
Nachbarländern das Stichwort im
europaindex für die digitale Wirtschaft
und Gesellschaft liegt Deutschland im
Moment nur auf Platz 13 von 27
EU-Staaten bei der Durchdringung von
Unternehmer also Integration der
Datentechnik sogar nur auf Platz Nummer
16 das muss sich ändern Markus Reichel
jetzt für die CDU CSU
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen also ich habe
mir heute schon gedacht dass wir in den
ersten Minuten wieder mal die ersten
Münzen ins 16 Jahre Phrasenschwein
hineinschmeißen müssen ein Jahr nach der
Wahl im übrigen aber dass wir heute wenn
wir über die deutsche digitalstrategie
sprechen bis zur Berlusconi kommen Herr
Zimmermann das hätte ich mir echt nicht
erwartet
lassen Sie uns jetzt mal aber ein
bisschen genauer über das Thema der
sicheren digitalen Identitäten sprechen
warum sind sie so wichtig da gibt es das
standardbeispiel also dass ich jetzt von
meinem von meiner Couch in Dresden eben
ganz bequem hier meine Wohnung ummelden
kann das ist ein super Sache aber
zweites Beispiel wozu das hinführen soll
die Ermöglichung eines sicheren eine
souveränen Umgangs mit Daten
Gesundheitsdaten Forschungsdaten und
etwas was viel zu kurz kommt im Kontext
der Modernisierung auch unserer
Industrie für das Internet of things
benötigen wir sichere digitale
Identitäten von Menschen aber eben auch
in der Zukunft von Maschinen und kurz
gesagt hier steckt ein ungeheures
Potenzial zu unserer aller nutzen und
eine enorme Chance auch für die
Entbürokratisierung
Herr Minister wissen sie haben bei der
Vorstellung der digitalstrategie
versprochen wir verlieren uns nicht in
Zukunftsvisionen wir gehen jetzt die
Digitalisierung ganz konkret an und ich
muss auch sagen ich finde es
hervorragend dass auch sie in der
digitalstrategie die sicheren digitalen
Identitäten als eines der Projekte mit
Hebelwirkung ganz ganz oben auf die
Agenda setzen und nach ihrer Ansage
hatte ich natürlich jetzt auch gehofft
dass wir viele ganz konkrete Dinge dazu
lesen werden ich muss allerdings sagen
schon bereits bei den Zielstellungen
fehlanzeige
erstes Ziel was sie sagen im mindestens
fünf Wirtschaftssektoren soll bis 2025
eine staatlich bereitgestellte digitale
ID zur Identifizierung genutzt werden da
sage ich warum denn gerade fünf warum
nicht zehn welches Sektoren sind gemeint
welche Anwendungsfälle ein zweites Ziel
was Sie angeben der Personalausweis der
Führerschein sollen bis 2025 auch als
digitale Nachweise zur Nutzung mit
mobilen Endgeräten verfügbar sein dazu
sage ich ich finde es toll dass die gute
Projekte der CDU geführten
Bundesregierung fortführen aber es kann
doch nicht sein dass sie sich darauf
beschränken jetzt 2022 nur die Projekte
der Vorgängerregierung als Ziel zu
erklären und zu Ende zu bringen da muss
es doch mehr geben
so viel aber zu ihren Zielen bei der
Umsetzungsplanung sieht es ehrlich
gesagt auch nicht viel besser aus da
fehlen ganz maßgebliche ganz konkrete
Dinge sie lassen offen wie Sie vorgehen
wollen um sichere digitale Identitäten
besser im Markt zu verbreiten konkret
denke ich daran dass wir mal dafür
sorgen dass der Chip auf diesem
Personalausweis der im übrigen im
schönen Dresden produziert wird dass der
mal freigeschalten wird und dass das
dass es dazu auch eine entsprechende
Marketingkampagne gibt zweitens sie
lassen offen was mit den
schaufensterprojekten des bmwk
eigentlich passieren soll die sie
stecken eine ganze Menge Geld hier in
tolle Projekte aber nutzen sie das auch
sie lassen offen wie die Bundesregierung
eine digitale Identität in Europa
etablieren möchte suchen Sie Ihre
interagiert nationale Lösungen oder eine
neue für alle und schließlich sie lassen
offen wie die Bundesregierung überhaupt
zu einer europäischen ID Wallet steht
das Thema wird überhaupt nicht
angesprochen ihr papiertätigt keine
Aussage zu den europäischen Pilot
Arbeiten an denen die Bundesregierung
mitarbeitet also mein Fazit digitale
Identität ist eines ihrer hebeprojekte
sehr gut und trotzdem ist es erstaunlich
unkonkret das ist nicht gut und sie
gehen kaum nennenswert hier über die
Pläne der alten Bundesregierung hinaus
und die Chancen des europäischen eiders
novellierungsprozesses nutzen sie leider
gar nicht unter digital first da
verstehen wir etwas anderes Herr Wissing
sie haben versprochen er ist ganz
konkret zu machen wir warten darauf
vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
nächste Rednerin für die Fraktion Rösner
jetzt die bündnisgrüne ist Vorsitzende
im Ausschuss für digitales des Deutschen
Bundestages
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin ich darf ja schon seit
2009 die digitalpolitik und auch den
Breitbandausbau hier im Bundestag
begleiten und ich glaube ich muss mal
ein paar Erinnerungslücken füllen also
was haben denn die Vorgängerregierung
gemacht sie haben sich überboten in den
Zielen des Breitbandausbaus
2009 waren es zwei Mbit dann 50 dann 100
dann irgendwann Gigabit und Sie haben
nichts davon erreicht und warum nicht
weil sie nämlich völlig falsche Weichen
gestellt haben sie haben auf die
vectoring-technologie gesetzt und damit
Kupfer aufgepimpt was den
Glasfaserausbau die Grundlage der
digitalpolitik was den Glasfaserausbau
verhindert hat das ist doch alles andere
als ein digitaler Aufbruch
ist die nachhaltigste Technologie das
haben wir hier immer schon gesagt und
sie verbraucht übrigens auch am
wenigsten Energie auch deshalb brauchen
wir die Migration von Kupfer ins Glas
und seit Jahren warten die Menschen auf
einen schnellen Internetanschluss sie
kriegten ihn versprochen aber er wurde
nicht ausgebaut und mir ist immer noch
schleierhaft dass in neubausgebieten es
nicht standardmäßig passiert das
Glasfaser bis zu den Häusern ausgebaut
wird da müssen wir ans TKG ran lieber
Herr Wissing da werden wir zusammen dran
arbeiten damit wir bis 2030 alle
Wohnungen mit Glasfaser versorgt
bekommen muss jetzt ordentlich Dampf
gemacht werden beim flächendeckenden
Ausbau und das geht übrigens auch für
den mobilfunkausbau im ländlichen Raum
die Anhörung am Montag hat gezeigt es
liegt viel Arbeit vor uns um die
Zeitpläne einzuhalten dafür müssen wir
die Länder mit ins Boot nehmen die viele
Verwaltungsverfahren vereinfachen müssen
damit Genehmigungen schnell erteilt
werden das ist dringend notwendig
wir erwarten aber auch
wir erwarten aber auch von der
TK-Branche und auch von der Baubranche
dass sie interne Verfahren vereinfachen
beschleunigen verbraucherfreundlicher
gestalten dass sie gegenüber
Mitbewerbern und VerbraucherInnen und
Kommunen verbindliche Angaben machen und
sich an die abgegebenen
Selbstverpflichtungen auch halten denn
nur wenn wir alle zusammen an einem
Strang ziehen und zwar in die gleiche
Richtung nur dann schaffen wir die
gigabit-ausbau und der ist ja die
Grundlage für die digitalpolitik für die
digitalstrategie und für einen modernes
Land vielen Dank
[Applaus]
Matthias David Nives für die
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion
[Applaus]
Daten retten Leben das mag in der
Theorie stimmen aber bis wir in Deutsch
Kollege hier fehlt die Begrüßung auch
noch mal offiziell jetzt unterbreche ich
okay
dann noch mal guten morgen zusammen und
guten Morgen
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
Daten retten Leben das merken der
Theorie stimmen aber in der Praxis haben
wir da in Deutschland noch einen weiten
Weg vor uns und deshalb ist es wichtig
dass wir nicht nur eine digitalstrategie
auflegen sondern das war auch der
Umsetzung Gas geben insbesondere im
Bereich Gesundheit und Pflege
im Bereich Gesundheit und Pflege möchte
ich gerne auf drei Punkte eingehen
erstens unsere Ziele zweitens unsere
konkreten Projekte und drittens unserer
neuen Arbeitsmodus schauen wir auf die
Ziele davon gibt es exakt zwei und das
ist erstens für die Patientin und
Patienten konkrete Verbesserungen in der
Versorgung zu erreichen und das zweite
Ziel ist dass wir es den Menschen die in
Gesundheit und Pflege arbeiten das Leben
erleichtern in Bürokratie abnehmen damit
sie mehr Zeit und Energie haben für das
woraus ankommt nämlich das Kümmern am
Ende ist nämlich Digitalisierung dafür
da das Leben für die Menschen besser zu
machen
bei den Projekten ist es erste ganz
zentrale Thema die neue digitale
Patientenakte denn die genial wäre es
wenn ich auf meinem Handy sehe welche
Impfung ich schon habe und vielleicht
eine Erinnerung bekomme wenn die in
einer Auffrischung fällig wird wie
sicher würde ich mich fühlen wenn ich
weiß dass wenn ich bei einem Notfall ins
Krankenhaus komme und die Ärztinnen und
Pflegefachkräfte direkt sehen welche
Vorerkrankungen ich habe und welche
Medikamente ich nehme um Komplikationen
zu vermeiden das will ich und das wollen
auch die Menschen zu Hause in Kusel in
Kaiserslautern und im Rest der Republik
das brauchen wir standardmäßig dass alle
damit arbeiten dass alle des einfachen
bequem bekommen in Deutschland und dabei
ist auch wichtig dass jeder und jede
einzelne die volle Kontrolle über seine
eigenen Daten behält und auch immer
sagen kann ich möchte das nicht oder ich
möchte bestimmte Dinge Sperrung oder
Zugänge verhindern das muss jeder für
sich selbst entscheiden können und dafür
tragen wir Sorge
zu unseren Projekten gehört aber auch
dass wir eine digitale
gesundheitsagentur brauchen und zwar mit
einem ganz klaren Auftrag nämlich den
die Menschen in den Vordergrund zu
stellen die im Gesundheits- und
Pflegewesen arbeiten und neue
Anwendungen und Infrastrukturen so zu
entwickeln einzuführen damit sie in der
Praxis funktionieren und Mehrwerte
bieten und eben nicht dazu führen dass
im Alltag die Dinge lahmgelegt werden
das muss der Auftrag für die neue
digitale gesundheitsagentur sein die
Nutzenden im Fokus
das dritte was wir brauchen ist dass wir
uns anschauen wie können wir die
Forschung Stärken wie schaffen wir es
das auch in Deutschland Daten in der
Forschung besser genutzt werden können
und wir sicherstellen dass neue
Medikamente und Therapien eben nicht nur
in Asien und in Kalifornien entstehen
sondern genauso in Mainz und in
Ingelheim
und mit diese Projekte die sind alle
schwierigen kompliziert brauchen wir
einen Modus der Zusammenarbeit mit den
wichtigen Akteuren im Gesundheitswesen
mit den Kassen Apothekern Ärzten um nur
einige zu nennen dazu gehört aber auch
dass wir aktiv mit den Verantwortlichen
für Sicherheit und Datenschutz
zusammenarbeiten schon jetzt im Vorfeld
um gemeinsam gute Lösungen zu finden
denn ich bin überzeugt davon wenn wir es
ernst meinen kriegen wir das auch hin
damit Daten Leben retten und zwar
endlich auch in Deutschland danke schön
Matthias David Nives ist 36 Jahre jung
ein Bundestag hat auch die Begrüßung
vergessen aber das war nicht böse
gemeint sondern eher der naseität
geschuldet
2775 und
3.493 an die in der Tagesordnung
aufgeführten Ausschüsse vorgeschlagen
ich sehe keine weiteren
überweisungsvorschläge dann verfahren
wir so wie vorgeschlagen ich rufe auf
den Zusatzpunkt 2 erste Beratung des von
der Fraktion der cdu/csu eingebrachten
Gesetzentwurfs zur Änderung des
Atomgesetzes
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
68 Minuten beschlossen
Damen und Herren also die
digitalstrategie wird jetzt in den
entsprechenden Ausschüssen weiter
beraten beraten ebenfalls der Antrag der
cdu/csu und jetzt geht es hier weiter
mit
der Änderung des Atomgesetzes ein
Gesetzentwurf der cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
als Erster das Wort erst
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitzender
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen vor 207 Tagen
hat der Bundeskanzler nach dem
russischen Angriff auf die Ukraine die
zeitenwände verkündet
eine Zeitenwende die in der
Energiepolitik bislang nur unzureichend
angekommen ist
Verbraucher Kommunen unternehmen alle
sparen Energie wo es nur geht die
Bundesregierung ist weltweit unterwegs
als Bittsteller auf der Suche nach
zusätzlicher Energie aber das
Naheliegende soll nicht getan werden
zu einer Neubewertung der Kernenergie
Fehlen dieser Bundesregierung wenn zum
SPD und Grüne geht offensichtlich der
Wille und wenn es um die FDP geht die
Kraft sich in dieser Bundesregierung
durchzusetzen
am 7 märz vor 198 Tagen haben
Wirtschafts- und Umweltministerium
diesen fehlenden Willen schriftlich
dokumentiert es wurde uns ein
sogenannter Prüfvermerk vorgelegt mit
dem Ergebnis dass die Kernenergie bei
der Bewältigung der Energiekrise in
Deutschland überhaupt keine Rolle
spielen kann und soll in Wahrheit war es
doch so mein Damen und Herren das war
kein prüfermerk sondern eine wie wir
jetzt wissen in wenigen Tagen schnell
zusammengestellte Zusammenstellung aller
Gegenargumente das hätte wirklich jeder
Praktikant in ihren Ministerien genauso
machen können
und seither ist viel Zeit vergangen zu
viel Zeit vergangen eine lange Zeit die
nicht genutzt wurde um den Weiterbetrieb
vorzubereiten eine lange Zeit die nicht
genutzt wurde um neue Brennstäbe zu
beschaffen sie haben nicht das
Notwendige getan um uns verdrohender
Stromanlage und Blackout in diesem
Winter zu bewahren
Stichwort Stresstest ein halbes Jahr
nach diesem sogenannten Prüfvermerk hat
Minister Habeck dann endlich sich ein
Stück weit korrigiert das Konzept der
Einsatzreserve für lediglich zwei der
drei Kernkraftwerke vorgeschlagen aber
auch heute ist er noch so keine weiß
wirklich was genau das sein soll wie das
technisch gehen soll ist völlig offen
der ernstzunehmenden Bedenken der
Betreiber werden von Minister Habeck
einfach abgetan wie das alles rechtlich
geregelt werden soll ist auch völlig
offen das führt die nukleare Sicherheit
zuständige Ministerium von Frau landka
zwischendurch erklärt der erforderlichen
Änderungen sei im Atomgesetz vorzunehmen
nun heißt es diese Woche im Atomgesetz
werden lediglich wenige Randbedingungen
geregelt was denn nun sie hatten Monate
Zeit solche Fragen zu klären noch einmal
sie haben zu viel Zeit verschwendet
anstatt schlichtweg ihre Arbeit zu
machen und uns auf alles Szenarien
vorzubereiten
für diese Bundesregierung ist lediglich
klar wann die Einsatzreserve geregelt
werden soll nämlich auf jeden Fall nach
dem 9 Oktober nach der Landtagswahl in
Niedersachsen was für ein
durchschaubares politisches Spiel zu
lastende Energieversorgung Sicherheit zu
lassen eines klaren rechtlichen Rahmens
zu Lasten der Stromkunden zulasten der
Glaubwürdigkeit von Politik und
insbesondere auch zu Lasten der
Glaubwürdigkeit von Deutschland in
Europa meine Damen und Herren
welches Signal senden wir den aus wenn
wir uns in der aktuellen Krisensituation
den Luxus leisten Kapazitäten vom Netz
zu nehmen gleichzeitig aber europäische
Solidarität in den Energiefragen
einzufordern Kohlestrom aus Polen
Atomstrom im Winter dann aus Frankreich
und gleichzeitig eigene Kernkraftwerke
abschalten das ist doch wirklich absurd
meine Damen und Herren
wir schlagen Ihnen heute konkret die
Änderung des Atomgesetzes vor denn das
Atomgesetz ist das passende und seit
über 60 Jahren bewährte immer weiter
fortentwickelte Regelwerk wir schlagen
eine Verlängerung des befristeten
Betriebs der drei noch laufenden
Kernkraftwerke um zwei Jahre also wie
auch von der FDP als Partei beschlossen
bis Ende 2024 vor
kein Ausstieg vom Ausstieg sondern
befristete Weiternutzung solange es
schlichtweg notwendig ist es geht um ich
habe sie gerade gesagt bis 2024 dann
muss geprüft werden wie die Situation
dann ist das macht dann die
Bundesregierung also wenn sie so lange
durchhalten können sie es machen aber es
geht darum dass Notwendige zu tun und
nicht ihren ideologischen Räumen
hinterher zu rennen
es geht um unzählige Kilowattstunden
Strom die uns Sicherheit geben was
unsere Versorgung anbelangt und die
natürlich auch zu sinkenden Strompreisen
führen werden wir bekennen uns zu
massiven Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien die uns aber eben allein nicht
durch diesen und den kommenden Winter
bringen werden meine Damen und Herren
insbesondere Liebe Abgeordneten von der
FDP in genau 100 Tagen ist Samstag der
31.12.2022 da erlischt die Berechtigung
zum Leistungsbetrieb der Kernkraftwerke
Isa 2 Emsland und Neckarwestheim 2
nämlich dann wenn diese Bundesregierung
nur diskutiert anstatt zu handeln
deshalb rufe ich Sie auf die
Entscheidung ist überfällig tun sie das
in der Energiekrise einzig vernünftige
nutzen Sie alle Optionen die Deutschland
in dieser prekärenlage zur Verfügung hat
stimmen Sie mit uns für die Änderung des
Atomgesetzes zu vorübergehend weiter
nutzen der drei Kernkraftwerke
bis 2024 so viel Stefan Wilger hier aus
der nächste Trainer ist Jakob
Blankenburg ob man im parlamentarischen
Beirat für nachhaltige Entwicklung er
kommt von der SPD und dieser Beirat ist
im Parlament so etwas wie er hat so
etwas wie eine wachhundfunktion es steht
in der Beschreibung es wird gebellt
sobald ein Vorhaben die nationalen
Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie außer Acht
lässt mal sehen was Herr Blankenburg
hier zur Welt
und schon
intern Weiterbetrieb der Atomkraftwerke
geworben hat da liegt uns nun auch ein
entsprechender Gesetzentwurf zur
Änderung des Atomgesetzes vor und die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union
fordern darin einen Weiterbetrieb der
drei noch am Netz befindlichen Reaktoren
Isa 2 Neckarwestheim 2 und Emsland
sollen bis 2024 weiterlaufen als
Argument verweisen sie auf die
Sicherstellung der Stromversorgung
angesichts der unbestritten angespannten
versorgungssituationen in Deutschland
und in unseren europäischen
Nachbarstaaten soweit so bekannt aber
aber was neu ist in diesem Gesetzentwurf
und worüber auch sie eben gerade weniger
laut gesprochen haben das sind drei
Punkte und die gehen wir jetzt mal
gemeinsam durch Punkt 1 und die
Sicherheit der Atomkraftwerke die spielt
für die Union offenbar eine eher
untergeordnete Rolle üblicherweise der
werden die Atomkraftwerke alle zehn
Jahre einer intensiven
Sicherheitsüberprüfung unterzogen und
diese Sicherheitsüberprüfung die werden
zuletzt 92 fällig gewesen wurden dann
aber ausgesetzt mit der Bedingung dass
die Atomkraft am Ende diesen Jahres
abgeschaltet werden die letzte solche
Überprüfung die liegt also schon 13
Jahre zurück eigentlich Grund genug die
Sicherheitsüberprüfung bei einer
geplanten Laufzeitverlängerung sofort
anzugehen das zeigen auch die aktuellen
Mängel wie das ventileck am AKW Isa 2
aber der aber der Gesetzentwurf der
Union sieht stattdessen vor dass das
Ergebnis einer Sicherheitsüberprüfung
erst bis Ende 2023 vorgelegt werden soll
also in über einem Jahr
Punkt 2 die Union spricht offiziell über
einen Weiterbetrieb der Atomkraftwerke
bis 2024
also zwei Jahre länger als geplant
schauen wir aber in den Gesetzentwurf
dann zeigt sich dass sich die Union eine
Hintertür für ein deutlich längeren
Weiterbetrieb offenhält die
Bundesregierung soll bis Ende August
2024 einen Bericht vorlegen ob die
energieversorgungskrise anhält sollte
das der Fall sein denn will die Union
die Atomkraftwerke noch länger laufen
lassen aber aber und jetzt da wird es
richtig interessant die Union will die
Entscheidung über einen Weiterbetrieb
der Atomkraftwerke nicht nur von der
Energiesicherheit abhängig machen wie
wir eben gerade gehört haben sie will
sich auch zum einen die Preisentwicklung
anschauen zum anderen aber auch die
Einhaltung der Klimaziele mit
einbeziehen und gerade das ist
bemerkenswert das ist bemerkenswert
bleiben sie Energiepreise also hoch und
sehen wir in zwei Jahren höhere
CO2-Emissionen als erwartet dann hätte
das ein noch längeres weiter so bei der
Atomkraft zur Folge Bravo liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
die eigenen Versäumnisse beim Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien und beim
Klimaschutz aus den letzten Jahren
werden dann also zu Begründung für die
weiteren Notwendigkeit der Atomenergie
genutzt
und und das bringt mich dann auch direkt
zu Punkt 3 dem Märchen vom Beitrag der
Atomenergie zum Klimaschutz dass die
afd-fraktion dieses Märchen gern erzählt
das wissen wir bereits aber nun springt
die Union hier offenbar auch auf diesen
Zug mit auf sie verweisen in ihrem
Gesetzentwurf explizit auf den wichtigen
Beitrag des verlängerten Betriebs der
AKW zu Weiterverfolgung der nationalen
Klimaziele aber dabei ist klar dass
Atomenergie keineswegs CO2-neutral ist
bei der Stromproduktion selber ja da
darf man ruhig mal klatschen
bei der bei der Stromproduktion selbst
da werden zwar kaum Treibhausgase
freigesetzt vor und nach der
Stromproduktion da ist das aber anders
und betrachtet man den gesamten
Lebensweg auf der Atomenergie vom
Uranabbau da können Sie auch gerne mal
die Freundinnen und Freunde in Sachsen
fragen wie sie das bei der Wismut damals
fanden bis hin zur Endlagerung da ist
die Klimabilanz von Atomkraftwerken
verheerend von den Gefahren des
radioaktiven Atommülls ganz zu schweigen
geht es uns geht es uns also um Klima
und umweltfreundliche Energieerzeugung
da bleibt deshalb nur ein wirklich
nachhaltiger weg und das ist der Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energie und da da Liebe
Union da müssen sie sich die Frage
gefallen lassen ob sie unter dem
denkmatel der schon wieder auf keinen
Atomdebatte mit ihrer verhinderungs- und
verzögerungspolitik der letzten Jahre
fortfahren wollen nicht umsonst sieht
der zweite Stresstest der
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber im schlimmsten
und ich wiederhole im schlimmsten
Szenario nur im Süden Deutschlands das
Risiko temporärer strommangelsituation
hier wurde der Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien in den letzten Jahren mit
Instrumenten wieder 10h-regel im Bereich
Windkraft systematisch verhindert
mit dem immer gleichen Debatten über die
Rückkehr zu Atomenergie da verschwenden
wir wertvolle Zeit auf dem Weg zu einer
wahrlich kostengünstigen
umweltfreundlichen und emissionsarmen
Energieerzeugung zu einer
Energieerzeugung auf Basis von
erneuerbaren Energien liebe Kolleginnen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union
lassen Sie uns gemeinsam die
Rahmenbedingungen für erneuerbare
Energien verbessern statt die Atomkraft
wiederzubeleben dafür liegen genug
Vorschläge auf dem Tisch gemeinsam
können wir es anpacken vielen Dank
Jakob Blankenburg war das der noch mal
dargestellt hat dass der Weg weiter mit
der Atomkraft der falsche Seite Ausbeute
erneuerbaren Energien bringt die Lösung
Carsten Hills jetzt für die afd-fraktion
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
liebe Landsleute AFD wirkt die CDU
bringt als zweite Fraktion im Deutschen
Bundestag einen Gesetzentwurf ein indem
sie fordert die drei noch am Netz
befindlichen
Kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen zu lassen
inhaltliches gegen den Gesetzentwurf
nicht viel einzuwenden allerdings ist ja
nicht notwendig da die afd-fraktion
bereits einen entsprechenden
Gesetzentwurf eingebracht hat dem sie
heute Abend einfach zustimmen müssen es
stellt sich die Frage hat die CDU unter
Zwischenzeit begriffen dass es ein
fataler Fehler war aus der Kernkraft aus
rein politischen Kalkül auszusteigen
oder sind es nur die Umfragewerte nach
denen eine Mehrheit der Bevölkerung die
weiter Nutzung der Kernkraft befürwortet
wenn Frau Merkel nicht ohne ein
vernünftiges Argument den Ausstieg
beschlossen hätte
Ständen kugelhaufenreaktoren eine
deutsche Erfindung in Deutschland und
nicht in China in Deutschland Stände der
erste Test flüssig-brennstoffreaktor und
nicht in China eine Diskussion über
Endlager gebe es gar nicht mehr weil die
Reststoffe der heutigen Kernkraftwerke
in flüssig brennstoffreaktoren
verarbeitet werden wir wären weiterhin
Weltspitze bei Kernkraft und nicht ein
Land mit der dümmsten Energiepolitik der
Welt das Potenzial der Kernkraft ist
nicht mal ansatzweise ausgeschöpft die
eingeschränkten kognitiven Fähigkeiten
der meisten hier auf der linken Seite
verhindern dass sie dieses Potenzial
erkennen neben ihnen sitzen
machtversessene
Opportunisten die den Grünen Ideologen
einfach nur Folgen davon gibt es bei der
CDU auch einige oder wie eine ehemalige
CDU-Bundestagsabgeordnete sie nannte
Linke und Grüne Spender die aus ihrer
Sicht die CDU seit Merkels macht
Übernahme geflutet haben aber es gibt
auch ausgesprochene kernkraft-fans und
ich hoffe dass diese in der CDU bald
wieder das energiepolitische Zepter
übernehmen
im Moment sind es eher die die nur den
Wählerstimmen hinterher hecheln und sich
erst zur Kernkraft beginnen seit
Demoskopen herausgefunden haben dass ich
dafür eine Mehrheit in der Bevölkerung
findet im Gegensatz zur CDU steht die
AFD seit ihrer Gründung zur Kernkraft
weil es die sauberste effizienteste und
platzsparendste Energiequelle ist wir
haben dazu zig Anträge hier im Bundestag
eingebracht und wurden dafür
niedergeschrieben vor allem von links
aber auch von den ehemals Liberalen die
sind in der Zwischenzeit wahrscheinlich
aufgrund der rapide zurückgehenden
Zustimmungswerte auch auf den zu
Kernkraft aufgesprungen übereinstimmen
sagten Herr Lindner unterdürr man müsse
jetzt die parteipolitischen Spielchen
lassen und Herr dürr ich zitiere es sei
verantwortungslos die letzten drei
Kernkraftwerke abzuschalten Kollegen sie
haben heute Abend die Möglichkeit ihren
Worten auch Daten folgen zu lassen
lassen sie parteipolitische Spielchen
seien sie nicht verantwortungslos und
stimmen Sie heute abend unserem Gesetz
zu
tun sie es nicht sind sie gelinde gesagt
im höchsten Maße unglaubwürdig ich
bedanke mich für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
die nächste Rednerin in der Debatte ist
Julia Verlinden von den Bündnisgrünen
sie ich sie zuständige stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der bündnisgründung
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und zuhörende ich kann es
kurz machen
Atomkraft ist unflexibel riskant und
teuer je länger die Atomkraftwerke
laufen desto länger stehen sie auch der
Energiewende im Weg sie blockieren den
Ausbau der Erneuerbaren und zu diesem
Fazit ist letzte Woche auch das
Ifo-Institut noch mal gekommen
den Widerspruch erwähnt was läuft da
eigentlich in Bayern das wirkt doch nach
einem sehr seltsamen Gleichschritt von
Ehe und Tochter Preußen Elektra und der
Staatskanzlei erst behauptet man das AKW
Isa 2 könnte ohne Probleme noch viele
Monate einfach so weiterlaufen sogar
Herr Merz hat sich da persönlich von vor
Ort überzeugt aber jetzt stellt sich
raus man hat vergessen zu erwähnen dass
AKW muss repariert werden
plus es scheint auch gar nicht mehr so
viel Brennstoff vorhanden zu sein wie
Herr Söder uns weiß machen wollte hat
das Kraftwerk überhaupt noch genug Kraft
nach der Reparatur wieder hochzufahren
dafür dass die letzten AKWs kurz vor der
Rente sind produzieren sie von der Union
reichlich viel heiße Luft
Frau Dr Verlinden gestatten sie eine
Zwischenfrage oder Bemerkung aus der
cdu/cs
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin Dr verlinken
für die Möglichkeit der Zwischenfrage
sind Sie bereit zu akzeptieren und mir
zuzustimmen dass die Situation bei den
bayerischen Kernkraftwerk insoweit
unproblematisch ist als noch nicht
einmal ein meldepflichtiger Vorgang
vorliegt wenn ein Ventil repariert
werden muss und sind Sie bereit zu
akzeptieren dass das unnötig
skandalisiert wird
lieber Kollege
lieber Kollege von der Union
wir machen uns hier seit Wochen seit
Monaten Gedanken darüber wie wir eine
Energiesicherheit gewährleisten können
für Deutschland und und wenn dann ein
Betreiber sagt wir bieten euch an
monatelang können wir hier am Netz
bleiben wir können zusätzlichen Strom
produzieren und dann rauskommt bei
intensiveren Gesprächen ach nee wir
müssen noch mal runterfahren wir müssen
noch mal was reparieren und dann ist die
Frage wann können wir wieder hochfahren
wie viel Brennstoff haben wir dann
überhaupt noch dann ist das keine
verlässliche Kommunikation wir brauchen
hier Tran
wir brauchen transparent was tatsächlich
der Zustand ist in diesem
Atomkraftwerken sonst können wir hier
keine vernünftige Politik machen sie
wollen
sie wollen unser Land mit einer Debatte
beschäftigen die wenn überhaupt nur ein
winzigen Beitrag leisten könnte aber sie
haben das aufgeplustert und ihren
Fetisch von neuen Brennstäben gepflegt
um davon abzulenken was in den letzten
Jahren in einer unionsgeführten
Bundesregierung energiepolitisch alles
falsch gelaufen ist
anstatt ihre Fehler anstatt ihre Fehler
Herr Merz endlich mal zuzugeben oder aus
der Vergangenheit wenigstens zu lernen
kramen sie in der Mottenkiste und
fordern ein Revival der Technologie des
letzten Jahrtausends wir ans Ampel und
insbesondere das Energieministerium und
Robert Habeck sind 227 dabei echte
energiesicherheitspolitik in dieser
Krise zu machen auf klimafreundliche
Energie umzustellen und mit
Umweltministerin Steffi Lemke das
Kapitel ashtonstrom endlich
abzuschließen denn Atomkraft ist nun
wirklich keine Lösung für irgendeins
unserer Probleme das einzige Problem
dass die Atomkraft aus ihrer Sicht
vermeintlich löst ist die fehlende
Profilierung der Union und ich muss
Ihnen sagen das Risiko das Risiko ein
altes Atomkraftwerk länger laufen zu
lassen finde ich deutlich bedrohlicher
als das Risiko dass die Union nur mal
lieber gerade gar kein anderes Thema hat
denn ihr Gesetzentwurf heute der zeigt
doch eins sie haben als Partei nie
wirklich hinter der Erkenntnis ihrer
ehemaligen Parteivorsitzenden gestanden
Frau Merkel hat als Physikerin als
Physikerin und als Kanzlerin vor elf
Jahren zur Kenntnis nehmen müssen und so
formulierte sie das selbst sie
formulierte das so selbst Zitat selbst
in einem hochtechnologie-land wie Japan
sind die Risiken der Kernenergie nicht
sicher beherrschbar und sie wollen jetzt
hier ein gesellschaftlichen Konsens zum
Atomausstieg wieder aufschnüren denn all
diesen diesen Konsens haben alle
Fraktionen diesen Ausstieg haben alle
Fraktion im Bundestag damals beschlossen
und zwar mit sehr guten Gründen wurde
dieser Ausstieg beschlossen diese Gründe
sind heute genauso richtig und aktuell
wie damals und wenn sie Union in der
aktuellen Situation wirklich wenn sie
wirklich einen Beitrag leisten wollen
für Energiesicherheit für Unabhängigkeit
von Energieimporten für stabile
Energiepreise dann bringen Sie den
Ausbau der Windkraft endlich in den
Bundesländern voran wo sie mitregieren
allen voran in Bayern danach danach
können wir weiterreden
oh das war's Julia verlinken also hier
die bündnisgrüne mit grüner Politik pur
auch mit den Begründungen und ich gebe
noch eine hinzu wir haben bald
Landtagswahlen in Niedersachsen in einem
Monat das Spiel sicherlich auch eine
Rolle danach muss dann noch mal neu
geschaut werden woher eigentlich die
Energie ab Januar kommen wird
Ralf lenkert jetzt für die Linke täglich
zittere ich bei Nachrichten rund um die
ukrainischen Atomkraftwerke
Artilleriebeschuss zerstörte
Stromleitung und Personalmangel beim AKW
saporoscia schwören die akute Gefahr
eines neuen Tschernobyl eines neuen
Fukushima herauf Union und AFD loben die
französische Energiepolitik Frankreich
steht kurz vor dem Blackout im August
standen von 60 Gigawatt der
französischen AKW nur 31 Gigawatt zur
Verfügung durchrostende Kühlleitung die
getauscht werden müssen spannungsris
bei einem Typ von Atomreaktoren erzwang
deren Abschaltung übrigens entdeckt bei
den zehnjährigen Sicherheitskontrollen
ist die Realität die AKW Emsland
Neckarwestheim und Isar hätten
spätestens 2019 diese zehnjährigen
Kontrollen durchführen müssen wegen der
geplanten Stilllegung 22 wurde darauf
verzichtet trotzdem glauben Union FDP
und AFD die deutschen AKW werden sicher
und könnten problemlos weiter betrieben
werden das ist naiv und das ist falsch
statt zu glauben halte ich mich als
Techniker lieber an Fakten am 19
September Teil der Preußen der mit dass
im AKW Isa 2 ein Ventil legt das wäre
kein Problem bis zum 31.12 allerdings
wäre ein ventilwechsel bei einem
längeren Betrieb des AKWs notwendig sagt
der Betreiber die Wartung müsste
spätestens im Oktober erfolgen weil die
vorhandenen Brennstäbe fast ausgebrannt
sind wegen fehlender Reaktivität könnte
sonst das AKW nicht mehr in Betrieb
gehen sagt der Betreiber das ist die
Realität die Bestellzeit für Brennstäbe
beträgt mindestens 18 Monate Herr März
dann sind die zwei kritischen Winter
vorbei die Brennstäbe bestehen aus Uran
54% des weltweiten Urans werden in
Kasachstan Russland und Usbekistan
gefördert im Jahr 2020 verbraucht nur
die USA Frankreich Japan und Südkorea 56
Prozent des weltweit geförderten Urans
ohne Uran von Putins Gnaden wird es wohl
keine neuen Brennstäbe für deutsche AKW
geben das ist die Realität
und Bürger
kennen Sie den Unterschied zwischen
einem Atomkraftwerk und einem
ddr-pkw-trabant
beide stammen aus dem letzten
Jahrtausend aber für den Trabant gibt es
noch Ersatzteile
DIE LINKE fordert die sofortige
Aufhebung der Decke bei solar- und vor
allem bei Bioenergie für ein größeres
Stromangebot wir fordern eine Änderung
der abgabensystematik damit Stadtwerke
den Windstrom für Fernwärme nutzen
können statt dass die Windräder bei
Starkstrom abgeschaltet werden das spart
Gas für die Gaskraftwerke bei Flaute wir
fordern ein Ende der Profitmaximierung
von Energiekonzern verstaatlichen wir
diese Konzerne
wir brauchen ein preiswertes Strom und
gasgrundkontingent für Bürgerinnen und
Bürger
und damit die Abzocke an Tankstellen
Energie und an Energiebörsen aufhört
fordert DIE LINKE ein preisdeckel für
Strom und Gas
und auch damit die kleine mittleren
Unternehmen finanziell überleben und
Arbeitsplätze erhalten bleiben
damit Bürgerinnen und Bürger
systemrelevante Dienstleistungen und
Unternehmen sicher versorgt werden
fordere ich von der Bundesregierung eine
eindeutige Belieferung Hierarchie
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union statt
über den Weiterbetrieb der AKW zu
fantasieren arbeiten Sie lieber an
umsetzbaren Lösungen vielen Dank
nächste Rednerin für die FDP-Fraktion
Judith skudely
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen im Juni dieses
Jahres hat sich der Wirtschaftsminister
an die Menschen gewandt mit den Worten
jede Kilowattstunde hilft in dieser
Situation
damit wurden die Menschen dazu
aufgefordert ihren Beitrag dazu zu
leisten mit der Energiekrise die durch
Putins völkerrechtswidrigen
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine und auf
seinen
EU-weiten Gaskrieg gegen Europa und
gegen die demokratischen Staaten
eingeläutet worden sind und auch wir in
der Bundesregierung wir hier im
Parlament tragen eine Verantwortung
dafür dass wir diese Angriffe mit der
richtigen Antwort beantworten und die
richtige Antwort ist eine sichere
saubere und bezahlbare Energieversorgung
für Mensch und Wirtschaft in Deutschland
zu erhalten
und da haben wir auch schon vieles
Richtige getan und darüber haben wir
heute noch viel zu wenig gesprochen wir
tun so wie wenn wir das letzte halbe
Jahr einfach gar nichts gemacht hätten
mit dem Wind an Land gesetzt und mit den
Wind auf See gesetzt haben wir den
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien
beschleunigt etwas was die letzten
Bundesregierung die letzten Jahre
verschlafen haben mit dem LNG
Beschleunigungsgesetz haben wir den
Einkauf vom Gas diversifiziert so dass
wir uns eben nicht mehr von einem des
Boten abhängig machen sondern künftig
unsere Energieversorgung auch von
demokratischen Staaten beziehen können
wir ändern mit dem
Bundesimmissionsschutzgesetz wir fördern
wir dass unsere Industrie schneller
umrüsten kann von Gas auf andere
Brennstoffe und wir werden die
Biogasproduktion in Deutschland erhöhen
alles kleine Schritte in einem großen
Reigen von Maßnahmen die uns in die
Energiesicherheit führen werden
aber trotz
trotz aller dieser Maßnahmen sehen wir
dass mindestens dieser Herbst schwierig
wird wir haben einen Stresstest der
besagt sogar dass das von grünen
geführte Wirtschaftsministerium
feststellt Achtung im Frühjahr 2024
können schwierige Netzengpässe können
schwierige versorgungssituationen
vorstehen das heißt dass wir einen
Vorschlag vorliegen haben zwei
Kernkraftwerke in der Reserve zu halten
die Frage die wir uns stellen ist der
Stresstest wurde nur bis 2024 gemacht
nur für diesen Herbst und Winter die
Frage ist reichen unsere Maßnahmen aus
dass wir auch im Winter und im Herbst
2023 im nächsten Jahr Energiesicherheit
haben weil das Versprechen dieser
Bundesregierung kann nicht nur sechs
Monate halten es muss mindestens bis ins
Jahr 2025 halten da wissen wir nämlich
dass unsere
unsere Maßnahmen greifen werden
[Applaus]
die kurzfristige Verfügbarkeit darüber
müssen wir gar nicht sprechen von
Kernkraftwerken ist und das hatten sie
Stresstests auch gezeigt schwierig ein
Kernkraftwerk ist eben nicht eine
Kaffeemaschine dass man an- und
ausmachen kann und gerade am Beispiel
Isar 2 wir haben es vorhin gesehen zeigt
sich dass wir eben nicht nur ganz
kurzfristig denken dürfen die sogenannte
lektage ist tatsächlich einfach nur ein
Verschleißteil dieses Verschleißteil ist
sicher nutzbar bis dezember 2023 aber
selbst im Falle eines
reservebetriebs müssen wir doch gucken
dass unsere Kernkraftwerke auf den
technisch höchsten Niveau sind und
selbst im Falle eines reservebetriebs
müssen wir doch die Sicherheit der
Kernkraftwerke gewährleisten und das
kann mit nachrüstmaßnahmen das kann mit
Investitionen verbunden sein wenn wir
aber diese Sicherheitsprüfung machen
wenn wir die technische Überwachung
machen wenn wir sicherstellen können
dass in einem Reservebetrieb die
Kernkraftwerke kunstfähig sind wenn wir
Geld dafür in die Hand nehmen ja warum
in Gottes Namen nutzen wir sie dann
nicht auf
und dazu
zu kommt auch noch eine europäische
Perspektive wir sind eingebunden in
einen europäischen Energiemarkt und
diese europäische Energiemarkt heißt
dass wir Gas von anderen Ländern
beziehen übrigens nicht nur auch aus
Russland sondern beispielsweise
unkonventionelles Erdgas aus unserem
osteuropäischen Nachbarstaaten wir
beziehen aber auch Kernenergie aus
anderen Ländern und ich möchte bemerken
dass die Energiesituation in all unseren
Nachbarstaaten nicht wesentlich besser
ist als in Deutschland und aus dem
Gedanken der europäischen Solidarität
heraus sollten wir auch alles tun um die
Energiesicherheit bei uns zu schützen
und die vorhandenen Ressourcen zu nützen
weil das unser Beitrag zur europäischen
Solidarität sein kann
uns Versorgungs
und versorgungs- und Energiesicherheit
ist übrigens nicht nur eine Frage der
Verfügbarkeit gerade heute sehen viele
Wirtschaftszweige sehen viele Menschen
das zwar Gas und Strom vorhanden ist
aber dass sie es sich schlichtweg nicht
mehr leisten können es reicht nicht aus
wenn wir genügend Strom und Gas da sind
wir müssen ihn auch bezahlbarheiten
damit ER den Menschen zur Verfügung
stehen kann
und auch in diesem Bereich sind wir ja
nicht untätig in der Bundesregierung mit
den energiepauschalen diese Woche mit
der
Mehrwertsteuersenkung auf Gas und mit
der Diskussion in Europa wie wir einen
Deckel auf die Energiepreise setzen
haben wir schon Maßnahmen umgesetzt und
haben wir weitere Maßnahmen invisier um
die Bezahlbarkeit der Energieversorgung
in Deutschland zu gewährleisten aber vor
dem Hintergrund dieser Diskussion sehen
wir auch dass die weiter Nutzung der
Kernenergie eine preisdämpfung bewirkt
um vier Prozent laut info-studie die
auch andere Parteien in anderen Punkten
zitiert haben
aber jede Kilowattstunde wenn aber jede
Kilowattstunde in dieser Situation hilft
dann muss am ist ja auch gelten es hilft
auch jeder Euro den wir sparen
meine Damen und Herren
meine Damen und Herren ich erzähle ihnen
alles und ich erzähle auch meinen
ampelkollegen kein Geheimnis wenn ich
sage naja vielleicht sind wir uns noch
nicht zu 100 Prozent eigentlich in
diesem Punkt
könnte sein aber wir haben uns
zusammengesetzt in eine Ampel weil wir
gerade in Krisensituationen sehen dass
wir unterschiedliche Meinungen
unterschiedliche Ideen und
unterschiedliche Lösungsansätze
zusammenbringen und bis jetzt haben wir
es am Ende immer geschafft eine
vernünftige von der Gesamtgesellschaft
getragene Lösung zu präsentieren und das
werden wir auch in diesem Fall schaffen
in dem Rahmen ich habe es gesagt wir
brauchen eine gesamtgesellschaftliche
Lösung nehme ich den Antrag und nimmt
die FDP-Fraktion den Antrag der
Unionsfraktion wohlwollend auf als
inhaltlichen Beitrag zur Debatte die wir
aktuell in Deutschland führen
ie hat gesagt wohlwollend auf eigentlich
müsste die FDP mit der Union stimmen
aber das geht natürlich nicht nach
koalitionsart Medik das ist nicht üblich
und da wird es sicherlich auch noch
Diskussion in der Ampel geben die FDP
ist für den Weiterbetrieb der AKWs
kurzfristig und dieser Konfliktpunkt
muss auf Dauer aufgelöst werden Jens
Spahn für die Union Stellvertreter der
Fraktionsvorsitzende Herr Bundesminister
Harbeck sie haben mir gestern lautstark
die Unterstützung der Opposition auch in
dieser Krise eingefordert das passt gut
zu dieser Debatte fangen wir noch mal
beim Problem an wir haben einen massives
Stromproblem seit Monaten wir haben
Rekordpreise für Unternehmen für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger beim Strom und
beim Gas die sich da schon lange nicht
mehr leisten können und und das darf
übrigens nicht vergessen werden jeden
Tag wird in Deutschland noch immer Gas
verstromt Gas dass wir eigentlich so
dringend einsparen müssen eine Lösung
eine offenkundige Lösung ist ein Mass
eine Ausweitung des Angebots es geht
darum jede aber auch wirklich jede Form
der Energieerzeugung die hier in
Deutschland möglich ist zu nutzen das
ist Problem und Lösung und dann geht es
um die Frage wie und gerade daher
Minister bieten wir Ihnen seit
Kriegsbeginn konkrete Zusammenarbeit und
Unterstützung an allerdings haben sie
viele unserer Vorschläge bis heute nicht
aufgegriffen und tun es immer noch nicht
nehmen wir die Kohle wir haben hier
schon im März gesagt Kohlekraftwerke
hochfahren um gasverstromung
runterzufahren
seitdem haben sie dann im Juli
irgendwann die Gesetze geändert haben
damals gesagt jetzt jedes Kohlekraftwerk
am Netz schauen wir heute Ende September
zwei kohlekraftwerke sind bisher erst am
Netz weil sie so hohe Auflagen und
Hürden gemacht haben dass sie nicht ans
Netz kommen schaffen Sie diese Auflagen
Weg bringen sie die Kohlekraftwerke ans
Netz da haben Sie unsere Unterstützung
sofort und unmittelbar
Biogas Windenergie Photovoltaik machen
wir seit März Vorschläge wie die
Potenziale die es gibt es geht um
steuerrechtliche Vorschriften es geht um
den biodeckel viele regulatorische
Maßnahmen bis hin zur Frage ob die
Windräder nachts laufen können wegen der
Geräusche das machen wir seit mehr als
Vorschläge die greifen Sie jetzt auf im
September das ist gut aber das alleine
reicht eben nicht und das bringt uns zum
Kern zur Kernkraft drei Kernkraftwerke
die in Deutschland noch laufen etwa vier
Megawatt Leistung die die haben etwa 10
Millionen Haushalte die mit Strom
versorgt werden und jetzt ist es ja so
Herr blankenburg
der Vorschlag des Ministers ist ja wir
machen die Sicherheitsüberprüfung also
sie müssen Sie übrigens die Frage ja
beantworten was ist jetzt mit dieser 2
wenn Isa 2 in die Reserve soll wie sie
vorgeschlagen haben muss jetzt eben dort
auch entsprechend das Ventil
ausgetauscht werden wird das jetzt mit
Ihrer Unterstützung passieren oder nicht
der Betreiber muss das wissen sie wollen
die Sicherheitsanforderungen müssen Sie
natürlich einhalten haben sie uns
wochenlang erzählt geht nicht sie müssen
das Recht ändern haben sie uns
wochenlang erzählt geht nicht natürlich
müssen sie für die Reserve das Recht
ändern sie müssen das Personal vorhalten
weil sie ja im Fall der Fälle die
Kernkraftwerke betreiben können müssen
haben sie uns auch erzählt ginge alles
nicht und sie wollen auch noch Geld dann
zahlen an die Betreiber jeden Tag jede
Woche jeden Monat dafür dass sie in
Reserve bleiben wir haben Personal wir
zahlen das Geld
Sicherheitsanforderungen werden
überprüft aber Strom soll nicht
produziert werden das kann man keinen
Menschen erklären liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und deswegen sollten diese
Kernkraftwerke durchlaufen
Pragmatismus muss jede politische
Festlegung schlagen Zitat Robert Habeck
aus dem März das stimmt und bei diesem
Angang haben Sie unsere Unterstützung
dann aber tun sie auch endlich
pragmatisch was offenkundig nötig ist
und erhalten wir uns für Deutschland und
Europa die Energie die aus diesen drei
Kernkraftwerken kommt übrigens wer soll
das eigentlich ersetzen wodurch Frau
verlinken sollen das ersetzt werden
sollen dann Gaskraftwerke die
wegfallende Energie ersetzen oder wer
oder was die Kohlekraftwerke sind nicht
am Netz wenn diese Energie wegfällt
werden noch mehr Gaskraftwerke laufen
müssen wir würden noch mehr gasverstrom
mitten in der Gaskrise das kann nicht
die Lösung sein in dieser Krise in der
aktuellen Lage
und ein letztes sie erbitten
lautstark die Unterstützung für ihre
Regierungspolitik die spannende Frage
Herr Minister ist aber welchen Teil der
Regierung sollen wir denn unterstützen
den Finanzminister der jeden Tag mit
seiner Fraktion längere Laufzeiten
fordert die Grünen und
Wirtschaftsminister die gefangen sind
zwischen parteilogik Jürgen Trittins
Lebenswerk und dem was notwendig ist für
das Wohl unseres Landes
die SPD die Liebe Herrn Blankenburg
angemerkt haben unentschlossen sind
also welchen Teil der Regierung sollen
wir denn unterstützen übrigens bei der
gasumlage wenn ich das mal sagen darf
das gleiche letzter Fan der gasumlage
die FDP Herr Mirsch Frau maast Herr
Janecek Frau dröge der Minister selbst
stellt die gasumlage in Frage hat
Zweifel an ihr beschimpft dann aber
lautstark die Opposition wenn sie seine
Zweifel aufgreift das ist auch ein
Grundstück politischer Rhetorik das muss
man sagen und anerkennen aber er hilft
ihm nicht und deswegen zusammenfassend
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir sind weiterhin und
jederzeit bereit zur Zusammenarbeit sind
es immer gewesen unser
Fraktionsvorsitzender hat es letzte
Sitzungswoche auch noch mal sehr
deutlich gesagt wir sind vor allem dann
bereit wenn sie tun was nötig ist für
Deutschland in dieser Krise für mehr
Stromangebot für bezahlbare Preise für
weniger gasverstromungen wir sind vor
allem dann zur Zusammenarbeit bereit
wenn Sie selbst erstmal wissen was sie
tun wollen in dieser Krise und endlich
konkrete Vorschläge machen und wenn wir
die zusammen starten wollen unser
Gesetzentwurf ist ein konkretes Angebot
stimmen Sie zu
vielen Dank Jens Spanisch der wird den
Fraktionsvorsitzende Wolfgang Kubicki
hat mittlerweile hier den
Präsidentenposten übernommen so nächste
ja nächster Redner ist der Kollege
Carsten Träger SPD-Fraktion und bei der
Unionsfraktion er ist Sprecher für
Umwelt Naturschutz nuklearer Sicherheit
und verbraucherschutzkastenträger
Präsident
der Spahn hat
öfters nicht mitbekommen das ist ein
Wechsel gegeben hat also grämen sie sich
nicht liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wir sprechen heute über die Verlängerung
von
Atomkraftwerken Verlängerung der
Laufzeit und Herr Spahn wir sehen sie
ihnen nach dass sie weil sie in den
letzten Jahren einen anderen Schwerpunkt
hatten nicht so ganz auf der Höhe der
Zeit sind was die Debatten angeht der
Stresstest hat ja gerade ergeben dass
die Verlängerung der Laufzeit dieser
drei AKWs keinen signifikanten Beitrag
zur Senkung der Strompreise bringt also
wenn sie ihn schon verdammen als
ideologisches Blendwerk dann werfen Sie
doch wenigstens vorher mal einen Blick
in die Ergebnisse überhaupt ist es schon
interessant wie die konservative Seite
des Hauses mit den Anbieter uns
versuchen der ewig Gestrigen umgeht ich
würde sehr genau beobachtet als die
verschiedenen Reden gehalten worden es
war irgendwas zwischen Versteinerung und
fast unverhohlener zu Stimmung
wenn sie von Ideologie Freiheit sprechen
und Pragmatismus
dann gebe ich Ihnen recht
aber wie können sie dann alle Argumente
die ein
sorgfältig durchgeführter Stresstest
gebracht hat vom Tisch wischen und wie
können sie dann unverhohlen über
jegliche aktuellen Entwicklungen hinweg
die Rolle rückwärtssensor zum Zeitalter
proklamieren das ist doch Ideologie
meine Damen und Herren
es gibt Meldungen von Sicherheitslecks
das beeinflusst offensichtlich die
hellhaltung der Union und die Haltung
der bayerischen Staatsregierung nur
wenig wer ist denn hier ideologisch
unterwegs diejenigen die sachlich
Ergebnisse Ringen um eine Lösungen aus
dem Stresstest den man sich sorgfältig
genau die Zeit dafür genommen hat oder
sie die jede Sicherheitsbedenken einfach
mal übergehen und sagen naja das war ja
sowieso nicht meldepflichtig
naja was ist denn passiert in Bayern
schauen wir uns doch mal an welche Rolle
spielt denn die bayerische Atomaufsicht
welche Rolle spielt die Staatsregierung
und welche Rolle spielt der tulf Süd in
diesem doch bemerkenswerten Vorgang wir
haben erfahren das Preußen Elektra in
den letzten Tagen wohlgemerkt letzte
Woche irgendwann die deutsche
Atomaufsicht darüber benachrichtigt hat
das ist eine interne ventileckage gibt
so ist die Formulierung natürlich nicht
sicherheitsrelevant aber wenn man länger
als den 31.12 den Reaktor betreiben
möchte dann muss man ihn noch im Oktober
runterfahren also liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich habe fragen was ist denn
das für ein Gebaren ich bin ja kein
Ingenieur aber gab es nicht einen Besuch
von einem gewissen Ministerpräsidenten
Markus Söder seinem Energieminister
Hubert Aiwanger dem für die Atomaufsicht
in Bayern zuständigen um Außenminister
Thorsten Glauber und ich glaube auch die
Sonnenbrille von Herrn März dort gesehen
zu haben weil eben genau jenem
Kernkraftwerk Isa 2 wurde denn da nicht
über Sicherheitsfragen diskutiert man
hat ja am 4 August eine Pressekonferenz
gegeben und es gibt ein Schreiben vom
TÜV Süd der übrigens viele Millionen
damit verdient hat dass er die Aufsicht
über die bayerischen Atomkraftwerke
durchgeführt hat in diesem Schreiben des
TÜV SÜD der sehr schnell zu der
Auffassung gekommen ist wurde der
Weiterbetrieb sogar von sechs
Atomkraftwerken gefordert also was ist
denn da los in Bayern was ist denn los
kann man denn diesen Herren wirklich
vertrauen wenn es um eine
hochrisikotechnologie geht wie die
Kernenergie
jetzt will die bayerische
Staatsregierung nichts davon gewusst
haben wir wurden am Montag aus den
Medien darüber informiert wer hat denn
die bayerische Atomaufsicht und wie geht
man denn mit so einer Hochrechnung
hochrisikotechnologie um ich würde ja
gar nicht sagen wenn man keine Meldung
erhalten hätte aber wenn man sich vorher
schon hinstellt und sagt wir san mir und
wir wissen alles besser und wir lassen
der Atomkraftwerke einfach sechs an der
Zahl weiterlaufen dann passt es doch
alles nicht zusammen meine Damen und
Herren
es bleiben Fragen
viele Fragen die wir gut beantworten
müssen ob wir diese
hochrisikotechnologie weiter in den
Händen dieser Herren sehen wollen die
gleichen Herren übrigens die in Bayern
die Energiewende
nein nicht vorangetrieben haben ich
würde sogar sagen an die Wand gefahren
haben ich sage nur zehn Haare Regel gibt
es immer noch ich sage nur dass es immer
noch die Übertragungsnetze für die sie
zuständig sind die werden
bei guten Verlauf vielleicht nach dem
Kriegsende fertig sein das ist die
Realität der Ministerpräsident Markus
Söder stellt sich hin und sagt wir sind
ein führendes Land der Energiewende und
es funktioniert nichts denn ein Ergebnis
diese Stresstestes ist es ja das Worst
Case-Szenario besteht darin dass wir
Netzschwankungen haben in Bayern und
warum haben wir denn Netzschwankungen
doch weil wir nicht genug Kapazitäten
aufgebaut haben um unsere
Energieversorgung selber zu sichern
sondern weil wir sie aus dem Norden
Deutschlands importieren müssen und
dafür fehlen die übertragungsnetzwerke
da schließt sich der Kreis und solche
Herrn geben uns kluge Ratschläge auf die
können wir verzichten übrigens auch auf
die großherzigen Angebote der zusammen
Arbeit wir wissen was wir davon zu
halten haben Herr Spahn vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Träger das
nächste Arena das Wort der Kollege Dr
Rainer Kraft afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident Werte
Kollegen zu Beginn ein ganz kurzer
Realitätscheck schauen wir mal wie es
ausschaut in Deutschland derzeit
Leistungsdaten Kernkraft 4
Gigawattstunden für Strom für Gas für
Neunjähriger Stunden was liefert die
Windenergie in Summe ohne offshore
eineinhalb Gigawatt das heißt selbst
wenn Sie jedes Windrad in Deutschland
verdoppeln schaffen sie es noch nicht
einmal die Leistung von nur drei
verbliebenen Kernkraftwerken in
Deutschland zu erreichen das ist ihre
Forderung für Energiesicherheit das ist
komplett armselig
dann liebe Bundesregierung herzlichen
Glückwünsche zum Erwerb von drei
Kernkraftwerken das ist wunderbar ab dem
1 Januar wird die deutsche
Bundesregierung der größte deutsche
Betreiber von Kernkraft von
nukleartechnischen Anlagen sein
gleichzeitig haben sie damit natürlich
fünf Kohle und Gaskraftwerk in Russland
mit übernommen und diese unterstützen
mit ihrer Strom und Energielieferung die
Waffen schmieden des russischen Militärs
das heißt in diesem Krieg in der Ukraine
unterstützen sie derzeit beide Seiten
das ist tiefste Heuchelei
und heucheln ist sowieso das
Aushängeschild dieser Regierung all das
was funktioniert das wollen sie für
grüne Luftschlösser in Deutschland nicht
haben kurze Auswahl Kernkraft wollen sie
in Deutschland nicht haben nehmen sie
gerne aus dem Ausland Kohle wollen sie
gerne aus dem Ausland Gas aus Tracking
wollen sie in Deutschland nicht haben
nehmen sie gerne aus dem Ausland das
CO2-freie Kernkraftwerk Emsland wollen
sie am Ende des Jahres schließen dafür
sollen dann schwerölbetriebene
power-budgets also schwimmende
ölkraftwerke auf den Flüssen
Norddeutschlands auf den Flüssen
Niedersachsens die Versorgungssicherheit
sicherstellen das liebe Regierung das
sind energieerzeugungsmethoden aus
Entwicklungsländern wie ihre
Energiepolitik
eine kluge Frau hat einmal gesagt man
kann die Realität ignorieren aber man
kann nicht die Konsequenzen einer
ignorierten Realität ignorieren diese
Frau Alissa sind auf Rosenbaum besser
wir können das around wurde bereits in
ihrer Kindheit doch die kommunistische
Mangelwirtschaft mit der harten Realität
konfrontiert und diesen
knallhartenaufschlag auf der Realität
das erleben Sie gerade in Ihrer
Energiepolitik
folgerichtig und zustimmenswert ist
daher der Gesetzesentwurf der Union er
enthält natürlich auch effektiv gesagt
nichts anderes als der Entwurf der AFD
über denen wir heute abend final
abstimmen würden und wenn sie da
zustimmen könnte man die Prozess
beschleunigen denn Zeit ist knapp der
Herr wird Minister hat schon viel zu
viele Monate verschenkt und dass mein
einziger Kritikpunkt Liebe Union Zeit
ist knapp die Betreiber brauchen für
administrative Dinge für Personalfragen
für routinewartungen alles kann
Hexenwerk aber sie brauchen Zeit
beschleunigen sie ihren Prozess und wenn
Sie ein Prozess beschleunigen dann
können Sie auch die Kollegen der FDP mal
zum Schuhe bringen denn die FDP selber
tut nichts einzelne Abgeordnete kommen
her und sagen sie würden gern
Kernkraftwerk erweiter betreiben aber
von FDP kein Antrag keinen Gesetzentwurf
und auch der Wähler Niedersachsen der
will wissen wo denn die FDP tatsächlich
steht auf dem Boden energiepolitischer
Vernunft oder will die FDP einfach nur
den Annehmlichkeiten einer
dysfunktionalen Ampelkoalition weiterhin
teilhaben das will der Wähler
Niedersachsen Wissen zwingen sie ihn
dazu
und bleiben wir noch beim Herrn
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck seine
Entscheidung nur zwei Kernkraftwerke und
nur in Reserve zu bringen ist
energiepolitisch falsch aber zumindest
hat diese Entscheidung eines aufgezeigt
nämlich wurde damit wurde der Prüfer
merk aus dem Wu komplett vorgeführt wir
erinnern uns im März diesen Jahres hat
das BMU in einer nacht-aktion oder es
meint festgestellt zu haben dass von den
drei verbliebenen Kernkraftwerken
keinerlei Beitrag für die
energie-u einfach nur unfähig eine
fachlich richtige korrekte Einschätzung
der Situation geben zu können oder hat
das BMU hier eine vorsätzliche falsche
Entscheidung uns mitgeteilt und mithin
die eigene Bundesregierung dieses
Parlament und die Bürger in Deutschland
belogen liebe Frau Ministerin was war es
denn nun
was nun Unfähigkeit oder eine
vorsätzliche Falschaussage aus ihrem
Haus dass wir Dich gerne wissen aber
eigentlich ist das auch schon egal beide
Versäumnisse sind so schwer dass sie es
eigentlich zurücktreten sollen liebe
Frau Ministerin Lemke gehen sie in den
Weg von Frau Spiegel
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Dr Kraft
als nächstes erhält das Wort Frau
Bundesministerin Steffi Lemke für die
Bundesregierung
Bundesumweltminister und Steffi Lemke
von den Bündnisgrünen hat jetzt hier zum
Antrag der
cdu/csu-änderung des Atomgesetzes das
Wort
Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich bin gerade angesichts dieser Debatte
dankbar dass wir in den noch laufenden
Atomkraftwerken technikerarbeiter und
Ingenieure haben die für die Sicherheit
dieser Atomkraftwerke garantieren an
jedem Tag den die Atomkraftwerke laufen
ich glaube dass wir in krisenhaften
Zeiten gerade mehr Sicherheit brauchen
und nicht mehr Risiko und ich glaube
dass diese Arbeiter Techniker und
Ingenieure in den Atomkraftwerken schon
so was wie ein Murmeltiertag hatten als
Herr märz und Herr Söder im August dort
in ihren weißen Anzügen auftauchten und
sagten sie wären im Reaktor gewesen und
sinngemäß hätten festgestellt dass alles
in Ordnung ist
ich halte das für keinen
verantwortlichen Umgang mit der
Atomkraft und deshalb sage ich Ihnen die
Entscheidung zum Atomausstieg steht
der 2011 in einem breiten in einem
breiten Konsens beschlossen Atomausstieg
kommt und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
von der cdu/csu ich verstehe gar nicht
warum sie nicht stolz darauf sind dass
dieser Atomausstieg kommen wird
sie haben in seiner Zeit beschlossen
gemeinsam mit der FDP und das war
verantwortungsvolle Politik die sie
damals durchgeführt haben und sie haben
damit ein jahrzehntelangen
gesellschaftlichen Konflikt in unserem
Land befriedet und deshalb geht es hier
nicht um das Lebenswerk von Herrn
Trittin sondern darum dass Frau Merkel
als damals zuständige Bundeskanzlerin
diesen Atomausstieg in unserem Land mit
unserer Unterstützung umgesetzt hat
[Applaus]
mit ihrem
Gesetzen geht diese Entscheidung
zurückzutreten Herr Bürger schauen Sie
sich Ihre Rede noch mal an genau das ist
die Stelle wo sie in Stottern gekommen
sind als es darum ging dass ihr
Gesetzentwurf nicht nur bis 2024 eine
Laufzeitverlängerung ermöglichen möchte
sondern darüber hinaus sie wollen das
Rad der Geschichte der Atomkraft in
Deutschland zurückdrehen und das wird
nicht passieren
es ist verantwortungslos wenn sie mit
einer hochrisikotechnologie so umgehen
als wäre es eine Kaffeemaschine die sie
ab und zu mal an und ausschalten können
die sie dann ein bisschen mit Wasser neu
befüllen einen neuen Filter reinmachen
und sie dann wieder anschalten
es hat drei Gründe warum wir aus der
Atomkraft in Deutschland ausgestiegen
sind mit einem Gesetzentwurf der CDU die
Nutzung ist risikoreich Tschernobyl
Fukushima und andere Katastrophen haben
das gezeigt
zweitens sie ist teuer und sie
produziert hochgiftige
Hinterlassenschaften mit denen noch
viele Generationen fertig werden müssen
und drittens die Sicherheitslage von
Atomkraftwerken hat sich im Februar 2022
in Europa massiv und radikal geändert
sie sind zum Kriegsziel des Krieges
Russlands gegen die Ukraine geworden und
das ist wenige hundert Kilometer von
hier entfernt und ich habe mir zumindest
nicht vorstellen können als ich gegen
Atomkraft demonstriert habe aus guten
Gründen ich habe ihnen die hier gesagt
ich habe mir damals nicht vorstellen
können dass wir über den Wiedereinstieg
in die Atomkraft auf Initiative der CDU
diskutieren während diese Kraftwerke
Kriegsziele geworden sind wenige 100
Kilometer von uns entfernt
und deshalb
und deshalb sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren wird es kein Wiedereinstieg in
die Atomkraft geben wir werden jetzt und
das haben Minister Habeck und ich
angekündigt sorgfältig prüfen ob für den
kommenden Winter 2 der noch drei
laufenden AKWs möglicherweise als
Reserve gebraucht werden um auf eine
mögliche krisenhafte Zuspitzung der
Versorgungslage reagieren zu können
gerade das drastische Versagen der
Atomkraftwerke in Frankreich wird diese
Entscheidung möglicherweise hier in
Deutschland erzwingen und deshalb ist es
richtig eine bereitschaftsreserve
vorzuhalten aber nicht daraus mit
billigen Populismus die Konsequenz zu
ziehen die Atomkraft um mehrere Jahre
verlängern zu wollen
Verantwortung zu übernehmen heißt auch
transparent und ehrlich zu kommunizieren
und das haben wir in dieser Woche getan
nachdem wir Kenntnis davon erhalten
haben dass es eine Ventile Cage am ak-2
am ihkw isa2 gibt die kein
Sicherheitsproblem ist das habe ich
direkt gesagt im laufenden Betrieb kein
Sicherheitsproblem ist aber ein
technisches und jetzt darüber
entschieden werden muss wie wir damit
umgehen es ist ein lange absehbares ist
ein berechenbares es ist ein
mechanisches Problem was dort vorliegt
das aber dazu führt dass das AKW jetzt
im Herbst wo wir auch schon eine
problematische stromsituation aufgrund
der fehlenden Atomkraftwerke in
Frankreich haben vom Netz genommen
werden muss und dass diese Informationen
von der bayerischen Atomaufsicht uns
nicht rechtzeitig mitgeteilt worden ist
ich lasse das hier mal unkommentiert im
Raume stehen
wir werden die wir werden die
notwendigen Antworten auf die
gegenwärtige Energie Situation geben
indem wir erstens die Erneuerbaren
radikal ausbauen werden indem wir
zweitens Energieeffizienz und
Energieeinsparung vorantreiben werden
indem wir in diesem Winter noch mal auf
alte energieversorgungsformen
zurückgreifen und dafür auch den
Reservebetrieb für zwei der drei noch
laufenden akbs ermöglichen werden wenn
er notwendig ist vielen Dank
am Anfang ihrer Rede hat sie gesagt die
Entscheidung zu Atomausstieg steht der
Thomas strieg ist entschieden zum 31.12
dieses Jahres jetzt am Schluss hat sie
es noch mal ausgeführt sowohl ihr
ministerkollege Habig wie auch sie ist
bereit ein bereitschaftsreserve für zwei
Atomkraftwerke über den ersten Januar
hinaus laufen zu lassen das dürfte noch
muntere Diskussionen geben auf den
Parteitag der bundesgrünen der im
Oktober folgen wird so und jetzt
müsste es in der Debatte weitergehen
nämlich
Frau Ministerin ich hätte sie gerne
gefragt
bei ihrer bei ihrer Rede
zu einem Vorgang
zu dem ich eine Stellungnahme des BMU
vermisse ich habe Angst einmal geschaut
auf Twitter ich habe noch mal geschaut
auf den Pressemeldungen ihres Hauses
dort ist über Einweg Plastikgeschirr und
über Urban Gardening Fassadenbegrünung
und andere
biodiversitätsfragen in jüngsten Tagen
getwittert worden auch darüber dass Sie
unzufrieden sind über diese Meldung
eines nicht meldepflichtigen Vorgangs
aus dem bayerischen Kernkraftwerk aber
ich sehe nur Töne des Schweigen zu der
Frage dass vor zwei Tagen mit einem
beispiellosen sabotageaktt
in Jänschwalde 200 Kilometer von ihnen
entfernt hätten sie näher zu schauen
gehabt
durch
ja kriminelle
landfriedensbrecher
ein Gigawatt gesichert Leistung vom Netz
genommen werden musste weil die dort
meinten in ihrem Privatkrieg sich auf
Gleise festzu kleben anketten zu müssen
und was was ich was alles und aus dem
Ministerium Dröhnen des schweigen wie
aus der ganzen Partei wo ist denn Frau
Neugebauer die ja ständig in allen
Talkshows ist und da auch mal ein Wort
zu sagen könnte was sind Sie bereit mit
uns zusammen heute der brandenburgischen
Landespolizei und Innenminister Michael
stübken dafür zu danken dass sie diesen
Zirkus schnell beendet haben und die
brandenburgische Justiz auffordern die
Straftäter ihrer Strafe zuzuführen
ja sehe ich schon sie haben das Wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Abgeordneter zum
einen ist es natürlich begrüßenswert
dass sie sich die Website des bmuv
intensiv anschauen und die studieren
zum zweiten werden sie da noch
wesentlich mehr Informationen finden als
das was sie jetzt so ein ganz bisschen
versuchen zu verhohnepeln und es tut mir
leid dass offensichtlich in der CDU die
Krise des Arten Aussterbens immer noch
nicht verstanden wurde aber das ist
heute auch nicht unser Thema
wenn Sie auf dieser Website weiter
geschaut hätten wenn sie dann ein
bisschen mehr Zeit noch investieren
wollen auch wenn sie auf meinem
Twitter-Account noch weiter schauen
wollen dann werden sie noch viele andere
Informationen finden und das bmuv hat
sich unter anderem in den letzten Tagen
in den letzten Wochen sehr intensiv mit
der Frage Sicherung der
Energieversorgung in unserem Land
auseinandergesetzt und dazu gehört die
sehr intensive Debatte die das bmwk und
das bmuv führen um sicherzustellen dass
wenn es notwendig ist wenn die
energieversorgungslage ist erfordert
sie sind aber gar nicht gefragt ich bin
gefragt glaube ich wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe und das werden sie mir
überlassen wie ich Fragen beantworte
Herr Abgeordneter danke sie werden dort
auch finden dass wir uns über die Frage
wieder Reservebetrieb organisiert werden
kann wenn er notwendig ist intensiv
ausgetauscht haben und das bearbeitet
haben und ich deshalb am Dienstag am
Montag die Öffentlichkeit informiert
habe über die Probleme er hatte mich
auch Frau Abgeordnete zur Frage der
Energiesicherheit haben Sie vielleicht
nicht hingehört weil sie zu sehr fixiert
sind auf ihre Details gefragt und jetzt
zu dem Thema dass sie im zweiten Teil
Ihrer Frage angesprochen haben ich habe
schon mehrfach wenn sie in meinen
Twitter-Account zurückgehen finden Sie
das deutlich gemacht dass ich kriminelle
Proteste dass ich kriminelle Blockaden
und dass ich die Frage der Gefährdung
von Sicherheit von Menschen durch solche
Proteste ablehne und sie kritisiert habe
öffentlich und klar und deutlich
kritisiert habe das habe ich getan und
ich wäre dankbar wenn Sie und ich
vielleicht dennoch ein Konsens darüber
herstellen könnten dass eine junge
Generation jetzt auf die Straße geht und
protestiert sie wird das morgen wieder
tun in einem friedlichen und in einem
zivilen Protest das ist dafür Gründe
gibt weil sich diese jungen Menschen
Sorge um ihre Zukunft machen weil ihre
Partei unter anderem den Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien und den Kampf
gegen die Klimakrise und das Arten
aussterben Jahre und Jahrzehnte lang
vernachlässigt hat vielen Dank Herr
Kollege
viel Applaus von im Grünen und SPD bin
ich jetzt richtig verstanden habe ist
die Ministerin damit einverstanden dass
ich Protestler festkleben und die
Versorgung zum Beispiel in ihren Spalte
in der Tat mit Strom gefährdet war nur
mal so fürs Protokoll die nächste
Rednerin jetzt kommt von der cdu/csu am
jahrwald
mit
Wankel nach gebe ichkeit erreicht man
gar nichts der Wankelmut von
Bundesminister Harbeck wird vor allem
durch die von ihm vorgeschlagenen
Notreserve für nur zwei Kernkraftwerke
deutlich die Einsatzreserve ist eine
totale Fehlkonstruktion und auch nicht
praktikabel wir halten die
Kernkraftwerke für viel Geld vor und
wissen noch gar nicht ob wir sie dann
wirklich nutzen das verursacht Kosten
möglicherweise ohne auch nur eine
Kilowattstunde günstigen Strom zu
produzieren das ist ehrlich gesagt
lieber Herr Minister liebe Frau
Ministerin ein schlechter Witz die
anderen Länder Europas schütteln doch
den Kopf über diese Entscheidung der
ampelregierung
die Menschen in unserem Land merken wenn
sie verschaukelt werden und Sie merken
auch wenn die Regierung einfach nicht
alle Optionen nutzt die wir haben auch
der Stresstest besagt das Netz Engpässe
drohen wenn wir die drei noch am Netz
befindlichen grundlastfähigen
Kernkraftwerke vom Netz nehmen deshalb
legen wir heute einen ganz konkreten
Gesetzentwurf vor mit dem wir die
gesetzlichen Rahmenbedingungen dafür
schaffen die Kernkraftwerke bis Ende
2024 weiterlaufen zu lassen denn das ist
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen neben dem
Ausbau und ich betone das neben dem
wichtigen Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien die einzig richtige
Entscheidung auch im Hinblick auf die
Energieversorgungssicherheit und die
Preisentwicklung
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
entscheiden sie endlich nicht nach
Parteiprogramm und Ideologie sondern
treffen sie endlich eine pragmatische
Entscheidung und unterstützen Sie
unseren Gesetzentwurf erste Signal in
die Richtung haben wir heute von der FDP
gehört
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
könnten wieder Vertrauen in unserem Land
zurückgewinnen wenn wir in so einer
Krisensituation über Parteigrenzen
hinweg zusammen die notwendigen
Entscheidungen treffen der Gesetzentwurf
bedeutet kein Ausstieg aus dem Ausstieg
sondern erstellt lediglich eine Brücke
da gleichzeitig müssen wir den Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energien massiv
beschleunigen und da brauchen wir auch
planungsbeschleunigung nicht nur im
Hinblick auf die Windenergie wie sie es
vorschlagen und ja ich komme aus Bayern
aus Franken wie man hört und ich weiß
was jetzt einige von ihnen wieder gleich
Zwischenrufen aber sprechen wir doch mal
über die Fakten Bayern ist spitze bei
der Energieerzeugung aus Sonne Wasser
und Biomasse kein Land hat so viel
grundlastfähige ich wiederhole
grundlastfähige erneuerbare Energien wie
Bayern Bayern
produziert mehr Energie durch
Wasserkraft als Rheinland-Pfalz in Summe
einer erneuerbaren Energien produziert
wir haben in Bayern mehr Bioenergie als
Hessen insgesamt an erneuerbaren
Energien produziert und bei der
Windkraft liegt Bayern allen Unkenrufen
zum Trotz auf Platz 8 was die
installierte Leistung angeht klar wir
können immer besser werden aber keiner
keiner von ihnen hat überhaupt
registriert dass wir in dem Bereich
nämlich in den Vorranggebieten in den
Vorranggebieten wo Windkraftwerke gebaut
werden Ausnahmen von der 10h-regelung
gemacht haben wir brauchen alle Optionen
im Jahr Wind Biomasse aber wir brauchen
eben auch die weiteren Nutzung der
Kernenergie und die Aufregung und die
Aufregung jetzt zu dem Ventil bei Isa 2
ist ein reines abblendungsmanöver das
ist nicht sicherheitsrelevant das ist
ein Routine mäßiger Vorgang wenn Sie
liebe Ampel jetzt endlich die notwendige
Entscheidung treffen würden dann könnten
wir die dringend notw den drei
Kernkraftwerke neben dem Ausbau
erneuerbaren Energien weiterlaufen
lassen vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
Weißgerber
als nächster hält das Wort der Kollege
Helmut Kleeberg SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
Präsident
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr
geehrte Frau Dr Weisgerber wenn sie eins
gerade geschafft haben mit ihrem
Vergleich dann haben Sie unsere
bayerischen Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ordentlich auf die Palme gebracht denn
ihre Zahlen waren ja nicht bezogen auf
Quadratmeter sondern auf gesamte
Landesfläche und da macht es dann doch
einen ordentlichen Unterschied wenn man
mit wem vergleicht abgesehen davon dass
nicht alle Vergleiche wahrscheinlich
auch in Bayern gut ankommt wie ich
gehört habe
es sind zwei Aspekte auf die ich
eingehen will der vorliegende
Gesetzentwurf das vorliegende Papier ist
nämlich ein sehr vielen Stellen
vollkommen unzureichend sie gehen auf
zahlreiche wesentliche Aspekte in keiner
Weise ein und das sind für mich einmal
die Frage hilft es überhaupt durch den
Winter zu kommen und der zweite Aspekt
ist welche Konsequenzen welche
notwendigen Folgerungen gibt es
eigentlich aus der von Ihnen
vorgeschlagenen zweijährigen
Verlängerung und ich will gleich mal
einen Punkt ein wenig Vertiefen der
schon angeklungen ist aber es lohnt sich
noch ein Moment darüber nachzudenken
nämlich die Frage der Brennstäbe des
Brennstoffes
in ihrem gesamten Papier kommt dieser
Begriff nicht ein einziges Mal vor sie
umschiffen ihn wahrscheinlich wissen sie
dass das sozusagen die Achillesferse
ihres Vorschlages ist ich weiß jetzt
wird kommen man hätte vor sechs Monaten
und so weiter über die Lieferzeit ist
schon gesprochen worden 12 bis 15 manche
sagen bis 18 Monate es kommt aber
folgendes hinzu und darüber sollten Sie
auch noch mal nachdenken in allen AKWs
werden die Brennstäbe im Wechsel
getauscht das heißt Brennstoff
brennstabwechsel stehen nicht nur bei
Isa 2 an sondern auch bei den anderen
Kraftwerken das heißt ihr Vorschlag
beinhaltet im Kern die Nachbestellung
von Brennstäben die dann wieder eine
Verwendungsdauer von 4 bis 8 Jahren
haben die man natürlich nicht sozusagen
im Anschluss nach zwei Jahren einfach
entfernt sie machen sozusagen die
Hintertür auf für die unbegrenzte
Verlängerung der Atomkraft und das
lehnen wir ab
habe ich gelesen
auf die Fragen der Kosten für
Steuerzahler gehen Sie nicht ein da kann
man sagen das ist ein bisschen in
angesichts der Lage
ist das weniger wesentlich das ist
richtig aber sie gehen auf das Thema
Sicherheitsüberprüfung ein sie
verlängern die Frist alles okay das kann
man so machen aber damit ergibt sich ein
anderer Aspekt den sie nicht bedacht
haben nämlich das Thema
Stillstandszeiten auch die deutschen
Kraftwerke haben Stillstandszeiten von
rund 30 Prozent das bedeutet auf drei
AKW runtergerechnet 1 steht immer still
egal was sie tun eins wird immer
stillstehen entweder durch Reparaturen
oder durch Sicherheitsüberprüfung oder
durch
ungesehene Notfälle also von daher auch
da funktioniert ihr Plan nicht
noch zur Vertiefung aus dem Stresstest
der Stresstest ist eine theoretische
Untersuchung eine Berechnung unter
bestimmten Annahmen was passiert wenn
und auch da lohnt es sich noch mal
hinzuschauen
der Strom fehlt im Wesentlichen im Süden
wir sind darauf schon eingegangen Ausbau
der Netze und erneuerbaren ausbauen die
Zahlen für uns Frau Dr Weißgerber ändern
daran überhaupt nichts vielleicht noch
mal interessant zu wissen im ersten
Halbjahr diesen Jahres gingen bundesweit
238 Windräder in Betrieb raten Sie mal
wie viele davon in Bayern genau drei
herzlichen Glückwunsch Herr Söder
der Stresstest sagt dass es ein Problem
gibt
theoretisch für wenige Stunden ich finde
es total spannend dass in Frankreich bis
zu 32 AKW vom Netz genommen werden
mussten von insgesamt weit über 50 ohne
dass wir netzschwierigkeiten bekommen
haben also das europäische Stromnetz
funktioniert offensichtlich gut genau
wir haben gasverstromt und da kommen wir
sozusagen zu dem Punkt nein da können
wir genau zu dem Punkt denn die
allermeisten die allermeisten
Gaskraftwerke die Strom erzeugen
produzieren gleichzeitig auch Wärme und
die können wir im Winter gar nicht
abschalten die werden wir auch im Winter
gar nicht abschalten weil wir die
Fernwärme sicherstellen das heißt ihr
Argument damit könnte tatsächlich der
Strompreis sinken es zieht nicht durch
die Kopplung zieht das nicht und
deswegen ist es richtig deswegen ist
richtig dass wir versuchen das zu
entkoppeln
vielleicht nur ganz kurz auch darauf ist
schon eingegangen worden für den
kommenden Winter sind die notwendigen
und richtigen Maßnahmen aus meiner Sicht
absolut in der Pipeline wir haben die
Gasspeicher gefüllt obwohl wir Gasstrom
auch exportieren zum Beispiel nach
Frankreich trotzdem ist es gelungen über
90 Prozent zu füllen das lng-thema ist
schon benannt worden wir haben genau das
was sie auch hier schon angesprochen
haben auf dem Weg nämlich den Booster
für die erneuerbaren Energien für die
Biogasanlagen für die Windkraft auch das
ist schon mit der Antworten für die
Photovoltaik und das alles flankieren
wir auch noch durch drei
entlastungspakete für die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger
für den nachfolgenden Winter sie
adressieren den ja auch wird aus meiner
Sicht die Situation eine völlig andere
sein weil wir werden mit den
lng-lieferungen werden wir dieses
stromthema so nicht mehr haben da bin
ich mir ganz sicher wir haben eine
höhere Verfügbarkeit von
Kohlekraftwerken und auch wenn der
endgültige Netzausbau sicherlich nicht
geschafft sein wird so werden doch
einige Schnittstellen im sicherlich noch
unvollständige in europäischen Stromnetz
geschlossen werden können das heißt ihre
den übernächsten Winter zu adressieren
geht viel zu weit und deswegen ist aus
unserer Sicht aus meiner Sicht das was
die Bundesregierung vor hat die
Bereithaltung völlig richtig da werden
wir Mittel des langfristig erkennen
können also einige Wochen vorher wie das
wie die Wetterlage sich entwickelt wie
die Füllstände der Flüsse sich
entwickelt wie die Füllstände der Kohle
Lager sich entwickeln wie es in
Frankreich weitergeht mit der
Atomkraftwerken und so werden wir das
tun und deswegen ist Ihr Antrag leider
keine Lösung dankeschön
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Dr Wiener
Kollege Kleeberger nächster Klaus Wiener
CDU-Fraktion
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Deutschland
steckt in der schwersten Energiekrise
seiner Wirtschaftsgeschichte und die
Folgen sind massiv ja die Menschen
erleben dass die Rechnung dramatisch
ansteigen und dadurch dass es sicher
wird der Konsum eingeschränkt werden das
allein spricht für eine tiefe Rezession
in Deutschland aber auch bei vielen
Unternehmen führen die gestiegenen
Kosten dazu das dringend erforderliche
Investitionen schlicht nicht mehr
finanzierbar sind ich spreche beruflich
schon seit vielen Jahren mit Unternehmen
aber noch nie noch nie waren die
wirtschaftlichen Sorgen so groß ja die
Existenzängste so groß und die
Verärgerung weil die Ampel sich
hartnäckig weigert wirklich alle
Möglichkeiten auszuschöpfen um die Krise
zu lindern um es einmal deutlich zu
sagen in dieser dramatischen
wirtschaftlichen Situation 4,2 Gigawatt
Strom aus dem Markt zu nehmen das muss
man sich erstmal trauen
was
was wäre sinnvoll natürlich das mal
vorneweg wir müssen die erneuerbaren
Energien ausbauen und zwar massiv aber
das wird Zeit brauchen das müssen Sie
doch mal erkennen und das wird Geld
kosten viel Geld weil Material fehlt
auch in Windrädern stecken übrigens
Seltene Erden und weil Fachkräfte fehlen
und im übrigen Deutschland hat in den
Jahren 2005 bis 2020 den Anteil der
erneuerbaren Energien bereits von fünf
auf 20% ausgebaut das ist
überdurchschnittlich nicht nur im
EU-Vergleich sondern auch im
OECD-Vergleich und sogar im weltweiten
Vergleich also von wegen 16 Jahre ist
nichts passiert dieses narrativ können
sich mal langsam schenken
bis wir allerdings ja Ja zu wenig bis
wir allerdings ja Erneuerbaren
hinreichend ausgebaut haben im Sinne
einer echten grundlastfähigkeit müssen
wirklich alle Optionen auf den Tisch und
dazu gehören eben auch die
Kernkraftwerke sie sind sicher und Sie
können ohne weiteres ein paar Jahre
weiterlaufen und ja das würde einen
Unterschied machen zum Beispiel beim
CO2-Ausstoß ich glaube die Klimaziele
gelten doch noch oder oder auch bei der
Preisbildung wer die Märkte zumindest
ein bisschen kennt der weiß dass es
manchmal in einer Mangellage nicht viel
braucht um wirklich preisdämpfend zu
wirken daher unser dringende Bitte seien
sie dass sie dieser schweren Krise
einfach mal pragmatisch und nicht
unflexibel riskant und teuer wie Frau
verlinken gerade gesagt hat seien Sie
zudem ehrlich zu den Menschen und legen
Sie keine Prüfer merke vor die innerhalb
weniger Tage von den Experten zerrissen
werden machen Sie keine Stresstests
die nur den kleinen Ausschnitt eines
streckbetriebs beleuchten und verbreiten
sie keine Panik indem sie eine undichte
Stelle bei einem Ventil als
sicherheitsrelevantes Risiko verkaufen
das ist lächerlich das ist lächerlich
das ist nicht mal meldepflichtig und
stellen sich am Ende nicht gegen den Rat
der Experten die wissen die
Netzbetreiber und der
Sachverständigenrat schlagen einen
Weiterbetrieb vor handeln sie im
Interesse der Menschen stimmen Sie
unserem Gesetz zur denn nur mit einem
verbesserten Angebot dann Energie werden
wir in der Lage seit diese Krise auch
ohne wirtschaftliche dauerhafte
wirtschaftliche Schäden zu meistern
vielen Dank
der Appell von Klaus Wiener von der CDU
CSU war er weiß natürlich auch dass die
Union in der Opposition ist und dieser
Antrag sicherlich keine Mehrheit hier
heute finden wird Harald Ebner jetzt für
die bundesgründe als letzter Redner in
der Debatte und die Änderung des
Atomgesetzes ein Antrag der
cdu/csu-fraktion
kennt wer die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
dann ist alles anders da stecken die
Seltenen Erden nicht in den
Windkraftanlagen sondern da stecken die
Windkraftanlagen selten in der Erde und
das ist der große Unterschied
ja niemand hat die Absicht niemand hat
die Absicht den Atomausstieg aus dem
Atomausstieg auszusteigen die Union aber
sehr wohl sie legen uns heute einen
Entwurf damit vor mit dem sie ungeniert
den Atomausstieg rückabwickeln wollen
und doch das wollen sie tun weil sie
erneute Prüfungen erneute Fortsetzung
der Verlängerung in ihrem Gesetzentwurf
schon vorsehen das werden wir nicht
mitmachen das sage ich Ihnen heute schon
und sie sind ja noch nicht mal sie sind
ja noch nicht mal bereit objektive
Fakten aus dem Stresstest der
Netzbetreiber anzuerkennen und sie
übersehen vor allem eines dass der
Stresstest eben überhaupt kein
Sicherheitstest war und der wundere ich
mich schon mit welcher nosch alons hier
die Union sämtliche Fragen der nuklearen
Sicherheit über Bord wirft sie bauen
darauf dass in diesen Tagen die Menschen
das gar nicht merken aber Sicherheit
kann und darf nicht nach Tagesform neu
definiert werden sondern nukleare
sicherheitsfragen sind nicht
verhandelbar
und mit ihrem Vorschlag mit ihrem
Vorschlag die längst überfällige
Sicherheitsüberprüfung weiter
aufzuschieben schlagen sie dem Fass
endgültig dem Boden aus ich habe sehr
genau gelesen und es lohnt es kann ich
jedem empfehlen und ihre offene
Laufzeitverlängerung die stellt ja nicht
nur die Sicherheitsfragen hinten an
sondern die erfordert auch die
Herstellung und den Einsatz neuer
Brennelemente und wenn sie jetzt sagen
dass es auf die eine oder andere Tonne
eine oder andere Tonne hoch radioaktiven
Atommülls übrigens heißt nicht kernmüll
sondern Atommüll gar nicht mehr ankommen
dann halte ich das sehr für zynisch und
wer jetzt noch mehr radioaktiven Müll in
die Welt setzen will der gefährdet die
ohnehin schwierige Endlagersuche in
diesem Land mutwillig wir werden das
nicht mitnehmen mit hinnehmen danke
schön
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Ebner und damit
schließe ich die Aussprache
interfraktionell wird Überweisung des
Gesetzentwurfs auf Drucksache 3488 ist
natürlich ein Gesetzentwurf ich habe
eben Antrag gesagt da muss man sauber
bleiben das der Gesetzentwurf geht jetzt
in die entsprechenden Ausschüsse und
jetzt geht es weiter mit einem ganz
spannenden Gesetz nennt sich
Inflationsausgleich Gesetz die Grünen
und FDP eingebrachten Gesetzentwürfe zum
Ausgleich der Inflation durch einen
fairen Einkommensteuertarif sowie zur
Anpassung weiterer steuerlicher
Regelungen und zur temporären Senkung
des Umsatzsteuersatzes auf
Gaslieferungen über das Erdgasnetz ich
würde jetzt die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
doch
den Platz eigentlich geht es also um
zwei Gesetzentwürfe zu Inflationen von
der SPD Bündnis 90 den Grünen und FDP
eingebracht einer befasst sich mit der
Senkung der Umsatzsteuer auf
Gaslieferungen und bei dem anderen
handelt es sich um das sogenannte
inflationsausgleichsgesetz die Senkung
der Umsatzsteuer auf Gaslieferungen muss
man ja im Paket sehen mit der Diskussion
darum ob die Kunden ab dem 1 Oktober
jetzt beim Gas die 2,4 Cent zahlen
sollen pro Kilowattstunde oder nicht die
Bundesregierung hat sich entschieden das
vorläufig erst einmal so zu belassen bis
man dann uniter komplett übernommen hat
das ist in drei Monaten bis dahin wird
wohl noch viel diskutiert werden und ob
das dann wieder rückgängig gemacht wird
wollen wir mal sehen also jetzt hier als
erster Christian Lindner der
Bundesfinanzminister herr Präsident
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen dieses
inflationsausgleichsgesetz und die
anderen steuerrechtlichen Regelungen die
die Bundesregierung vorschlägt sind Teil
der
krisenbewältigungsstrategie der
Koalition unser Land echt unter
galoppierenden Preisen das ist nicht
eine statistische Größe sondern es ist
für viele Menschen eine tägliche
Realität die Sorge um die
Nebenkostenabrechnung die Sorge ob die
Wohnung warm ist die Sorge ob am Ende
des Monats Geld dafür da ist den
Kühlschrank zu füllen die Inflation ist
eine Bedrohung für Wohlstand soziale
Sicherheit und die Stabilität unseres
Landes und deshalb ist die erste
Priorität der Bundesregierung diese
Inflation zu bekämpfen niemand wird
dabei allein gelassen
um soziale Härten abzufedern haben wir
zahlreiche Maßnahmen beschlossen
beispielsweise steht eine wohngeldreform
an es wird auch darum gehen
wirtschaftliche strukturbrüche zu
verhindern eigentlich gesunde Betriebe
die sichere und gut bezahlte
arbeitsplatzplätze über Jahre und
Jahrzehnte angeboten haben stehen
angesichts der explodierenden Gaspreise
vor größten und existenziellen
Herausforderungen die Bundesregierung
ist sich auch dieser Tatsache bewusst
und arbeitet deshalb unter Hochdruck
sowohl an Maßnahmen zur Bekämpfung der
hohen Strompreise als auch an Maßnahmen
um die gegenwärtigen Gaspreise für
unsere Wirtschaft nicht zu einer
dauerhaften Gefahr werden zu lassen
daneben gibt es aber auch Menschen die
ihren Lebensunterhalt bestreiten ohne
soziale Unterstützung Menschen in der
Mitte der Gesellschaft und auch diese
Menschen dürfen während der Inflation
nicht allein gelassen werden und deshalb
hat sich die Koalition darauf
verständigt dieses
inflationsausgleichsgesetz vorzulegen
unsere fiskalpolitische Antwort auf die
Inflation ist insofern zweigeteilt zum
einen geht es darum dass Angebot
auszuweiten weil das Preise dämpft
darüber beraten wir im Bereich der
Energieerzeugung siehe die Debatte zuvor
dafür weiten wir die
Produktionskapazitäten erneuerbarer wie
ich sie in eine freiheitsenergien aus
dafür werden wir auch die lng-terminals
in Deutschland
an das Netz bringen also angebotsausweis
die Frage aber jawohl die Ratifizierung
von ceta ist ebenfalls geplant und das
könnte auch nur der Beginn einer
erweiterten Handelspolitik sein aber
daneben Kollege Spahn geht es auch darum
dafür zu sorgen dass wir nicht
realwirtschaftlich eine weitere
krisenverschärfung erleben bei aller
Notwendigkeit sich auf das Angebot zu
konzentrieren darf auf der anderen Seite
die Nachfrage nicht komplett einbrechen
weil sonst andere Bereiche im
dienstleistungs- und dem Konsumbereich
sonst angesteckt würden und aus diesem
Grund kommt auch zur
Inflationsbekämpfung diesen
inflationsausgleichsgesetz eine
besondere Bedeutung zu weil es nämlich
die Kaufkraft in der Mitte der
Gesellschaft erhält und dafür sorgt das
andere eigentlich stabile Branchen im
Bereich Dienstleistung und Handel nicht
zusätzlich infiziert werden
da ist allerdings da ist allerdings
lediglich ein Kaufkraft Ausgleich an
Inflationsausgleich ist fügt sich dieses
inflationsausgleichsgesetz in die von
uns vertretene fiskalische Neutralität
ein wir wollen nachfragen und Wachstum
in dieser Phase der wirtschaftlichen
Entwicklung nichts stimulieren wir
wollen allerdings auch nicht durch
zusätzliche kontraktive Maßnahmen die
Nachfrage in bestimmten Bereichen
Bremsen also wir folgen der fiskalischen
Neutralität insofern gehen deutsche
Fiskalpolitik und Notenbankpolitik der
EZB auch in diesem Fall Hand in Hand wir
verändern den Grundfreibetrag den Tarif
wir erhöhen das Kindergeld und den
Kinderfreibetrag 48 Millionen
Bürgerinnen und Bürger profitieren von
diesen
inflationsausgleichsgesetz es basiert
auf vorläufigen Zahlen um gleich ein
Argument der Opposition vorwegzunehmen
das war auch immer so es ist hier
sozusagen ein trägergesetz dessen
konkrete Zahlen zu aktualisieren sind
wenn die Herbstprognose vorliegt das war
immer so und ist technisch nicht anders
zu lösen auf der Basis der bisherigen
Werte
erhält eine Familie vier Köpfe also mit
zwei Kindern einen inflations- und mit
56.000 Euro zu versteuerndem Einkommen
im Jahr erhält ein Inflationsausgleich
von
680 Euro im kommenden Jahr anders
gewendet würden wir nichts tun würde
diese Familie 680 Euro an Kaufkraft
verlieren angesichts der enormen
Preissteigerungen diese familien zahlen
für ihr Gas ohne eine Unterstützung
angesichts der enormen Preissteigerungen
ist das nur gerecht dass die arbeitende
Mitte der Gesellschaft ebenfalls bedacht
wird
ich appelliere
meine Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ich appelliere an die
Länder diesen inflationsausgleichsgesetz
zuzustimmen es geht darum die Menschen
vor zusätzlichen Belastungen in einer
Phase der Inflation zu schützen es kann
nicht sein dass der Staat von der
Inflation profitiert während Familie
nicht mehr wissen wie sie mit ihrem
Einkommen über die Runden kommen sollen
während selbstständige belastet sind
profitiert der Staat das kann nicht sein
und was für den Bund gilt dass er nicht
Profiteur von Inflation sein will das
muss in gleicher Weise auch für die
Länder gelten es gibt nicht nur
finanzierungsnotwendigkeiten beim Staat
es gibt nicht nur
es gibt auch private
finanzierungsnotwendigkeiten und
zwischen diesen beiden schaffen wir eine
faire Balance mit diesem
Gesetzgebungsvorhaben
vielen Dank Herr Minister der
Bundesfinanzminister hat noch einmal
vorgestellt warum ich so wichtig ist
auch die kalte Provision abzubauen laut
dem Gesetzentwurf wird die
anpassfunktion Steuermindereinnahmen in
Höhe von 12,2 Milliarden Euro im Jahr
2023 für nur knapp 18 Milliarden 20 24
Matthias Mittelberg für die Union dieses
inflationsausgleichsgesetz richtig und
beglückwünschen sie dazu Herr Minister
dass sie das in ihrer Koalition
durchgesetzt haben das ist ein guter
Baustein in diesem Entlastungspaket
klarer Aussage aber und das haben sie ja
auch gesagt es ist im Grunde eine
Selbstverständlichkeit denn durch diese
kalte Progression die ja gerade entsteht
durch den doppelten Effekt die Leute
kriegen Lohnerhöhung wandern im
einkommenssteuertarif höher werden höher
besteuert gleichzeitig verlieren sie
durch die massive Inflation an Kaufkraft
durch diesen doppelten Effekt wird das
Einkommen der Menschen entwertet und das
wollen wir ausgleichen indem jetzt die
Steuerschraube ein Stück zurückdrehen
und den Steuertarif Anpassen an die
Einkommensentwicklung das ist nichts
anderes als den Menschen eigentlich das
zurückzugeben was sie sonst durch eine
schleichende Steuererhöhung an leid ich
hätte fast gesagt an Verlusten erfahren
hätten nicht mehr als das es ist im
Grunde genommen sie haben ja lange über
dieses Thema übergewinde diskutiert es
ist die Rückgabe von übergewinnen die
dieser Staat macht auf Kosten der
Inflationsentwicklung mehr ist es nicht
wir haben dieses Verfahren der
Vermeidung von schleichenden
Steuererhöhungen schon seit 2012
eingerichtet im übrigen damals in der
gemeinsamen Regierung mit der FDP
seitdem gibt es dieses Verfahren wir
kriegen regelmäßig alle zwei Jahre die
progressionsberichte passen daraufhin
den Steuertarif an und das ist richtig
so dass sie das jetzt auch so machen
aber sie erwecken den Eindruck sie
würden hier jetzt wahnsinnige
Anstrengungen unternehmen um diese
Geschichte und auch ihr Entlastungspaket
auf die Beine zu bringen sie schreiben
das auch in ihrem entlastungspapier die
begrenzten finanziellen Spielräume
erfordern erhebliche Anstrengungen aller
drei Koalitionspartner wenn man sich
allerdings ihre Haushaltsplanung ansieht
und ihre sonstigen Planungen kann man
von diesen Anstrengungen nicht so
wirklich was erkennen wir erkennen kaum
Punkte an denen sie mal Einsparung oder
Umschichtungen oder neu Priorisierungen
vornehmen sondern im Grunde genommen
machen Sie alle Ihre Projekte wie bisher
und sie hier veranstalten ist lediglich
den Leuten das Geld zurückzugeben was
sie ihnen vorher durch höhere und
deutlich gestiegene Steuern aus der
Tasche gezogen haben sie haben nämlich
in diesem Jahr alleine bei der
Umsatzsteuer Bund Länder und Kommunen
gemeinsam annähernd 50 Milliarden
Mehreinnahmen gegenüber dem letzten Jahr
ich sage es nochmal 50 Milliarden
für jeden nachvollziehbar weil die
Preise ja so exorbiton steigen und Sie
darauf die Mehrwertsteuer zahlen und
deswegen verdient der Staat an dieser
Inflationsentwicklung massiv 50
Milliarden davon fast die Hälfte beim
Bund
so für dieses Jahr für dieses Jahr geben
Sie den progressionseffekt ja gar nicht
zurück sondern erst für das nächste Jahr
ihr Gesetz was wir heute hier
beschließen das wird ja erst fürs
nächste Jahr das heißt die 10 Milliarden
die der Bund in diesem Jahr zusätzlich
einnimmt die stecken Sie einfach mal
eben so ein und tun jetzt ganz großzügig
so bei ihrem Entlastungspaket als würden
sie den Leuten was zurückgeben sie haben
es den Leuten vorher aus der Tasche
gezogen und nichts anderes und wenn Sie
das Addieren die 25 Milliarden und die
10 Milliarden die sie an mehr Einnahmen
an Mehreinnahmen nur der Bund gegenüber
letztem Jahr haben dann sind das locker
mehr als die 32 Milliarden Beitrag des
Bundes zum Entlastungspaket insgesamt
ich will Ihnen was sagen
und Herr Minister Lindner hat ja auch
über das Gesetz hinaus gesprochen ich
glaube dass die Menschen in diesem Land
das hat auch die vorhergehende Debatte
gezeigt
allmählich das Vertrauen verlieren dass
diese ihre Regierung diese
problematische Situation die größte
Energiekrise Europas seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg
eine riesen Inflation seit höher als
seit 40 Jahren dass ihre Regierung diese
dramatische Lage für dieses Land
wirklich in den Griff kriegt ich glaube
dass die Leute da das Vertrauen
allmählich verlieren und zwar einfach
vor dem Hintergrund sie haben den ganzen
Sommer über verplempert durch interne
Streitereien die sie bis zum heutigen
Tage hier zum Thema Verlängerung der
Kernkraftwerke fortführen die ganze Zeit
erleben wir wie sie untereinander
zerstritten sind der Kollege Spahn hat
eben völlig zu Recht gesagt Herr Habeck
hat uns gestern aufgefordert wir sollen
doch mal die Regierung unterstützen in
dieser schwierigen Phase ja wir würden
es gerne machen nur wir wissen nicht wen
wir in der Regierung unterstützen sollen
sondern Herrn Harbeck unterstützen
sondern Herrn Lindner unterstützen wen
sollen wir denn eigentlich unterstützen
vielleicht werden sie sich selbst mal
einig
sie machen eine völlig verfehlte Politik
ein Fehler nach dem anderen erst machen
sie entlastungspakete wo sie nicht
zielgenau entlassen sondern das Geld mit
der Gießkanne irgendwie verstreuen dann
vergessen sie ganze Bevölkerungsgruppen
Rentner und Studierende haben Sie von
Anfang an gar nicht auf dem Schirm
gehabt das Holen Sie jetzt mühselig nach
die Leute die am unteren Ende der Skala
verdienen die schneiden bei ihnen am
schlechtesten ab die Kohlekraftwerke das
ist ihnen eben vorgehalten worden und
zwar zu Recht haben sie viel zu spät
jetzt hochgefahren das hat dazu geführt
und führt noch immer dazu dass wir
sinnlos gasverbrennen dass wir zum
Heizen viel dringender bräuchten als für
die Stromproduktion
ihre gasumlage ist der absolute Mist und
zwar von der Konstruktion her und sie
ist auch rechtlich völlig unsicher und
Sie haben ja noch nicht mal geklärt in
ihrer Regierung ob sie das rechtlich
überhaupt noch durchsetzen können das
ist doch eine Katastrophe und jetzt
erklärt eben Herr Lindner hier ja beim
Strompreis und Gaspreis da werden wir
noch was machen das ist aber doch das
was die Menschen am meisten beschäftigt
ihr ganzes Entlastungspaket ist doch
nichts wert wenn Sie an diesen beiden
entscheidenden Punkten noch nicht
weiterkommen und bisher sie haben sie
immer noch nichts konkretes dazu
geliefert das ist doch eine Katastrophe
keiner kann planen kein Unternehmer kein
Mittelständler kein Betrieb weiß was
Sache ist die müssen davon ausgehen dass
sie am 31.12 ihren Laden dicht machen
aber das macht ja nichts die produzieren
ja nur nicht weiter und verkaufen
einfach nicht weiter das bleibt ja
folgenlos wie der Wirtschaftsminister
uns erklärt hat
der Habeck hat gesagt wir hätten nur ein
Gas und kein Stromproblem das müssen sie
den Leuten wirklich angesichts der
Strompreise die durch die Decke gehen
erklären und dass sie jetzt in der
größten Energiekrise dieses Landes in
der größten Energiekrise Europas drei
funktionierende Kraftwerke die für die
Versorgung von 10 Millionen Haushalten
einstehen dass sie die vom Netz nehmen
wollen das ist schlicht unverantwortlich
der eine Baustein über den wir heute
sprechen Inflationsausgleich gesetzt ist
okay aber ansonsten müssen sie noch ganz
massiv Nacharbeiten wir sind gerne
bereit Ihnen dabei zu helfen aber Sie
müssen sich dann ehrlich machen und sie
müssen das Umsetzen wovon ihr Kanzler
selber spricht nämlich Zeitenwende das
heißt auch dass sie was wenden müssen
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Dr Mittelberg
des der Begriff Zeitenwende trifft dann
auch wir Redner zu nicht die sollen
vielleicht mal auf die Uhr gucken und
die Zeiten einhalten nächster Redner ist
der Kollege Michael schrodi-fraktion
Michael schrodi ist finanzpolitischer
Sprecher der SPD-Bundestagsfraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Präsident meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren die
Bundesrepublik ist einer der größten
Herausforderungen seit ihren bestehen so
wie in anderen
krisenhaften Zeiten wie beispielsweise
in der Pandemie als die Bundeskanzlerin
Angela Merkel und der
Bundesfinanzminister Olaf Scholz gesagt
haben auch mit einem damaligen Begriff
der Bazooka wir lassen die BürgerInnen
Bürger die Unternehmen nicht alleine sie
werden Sie gut durch die Pandemie
bringen so hat auch in dieser
Herausforderung der Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz auch jetzt der
Bundesfinanzminister für diese
Bundesregierung klar gemacht niemand
bleibt alleine wir werden gemeinsam
alles tun damit die Menschen in diesem
Land damit die Unternehmen diesem Land
solidarisch und gut durch diese
Herausforderung kommen
um über die richtigen Maßnahmen zu
sprechen muss man sich aber anschauen
was die Ursachen für die Teuerungsrate
und da gibt es in der Debatte eine
grundlegende Fehldiagnosen wie gestern
auch beispielsweise Professor truger und
Professor südikum in einem Antrag der
cocsu und eine Anhörung deutlich gemacht
haben zum ersten zur ganz rechten Ecke
zur fünften Kanal
es ist der völkerrechtswidrige
Angriffskrieg Russlands es ist Putin der